Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 79 unserer Sendereihe hier.
Und ja, was soll ich sagen?
Heute gibt es ein Novum, insofern als dass wir ein Thema aufgreifen möchten, was wir schon mal so hatten,
weil wir irgendwie festgestellt haben, und das tatsächlich auch schon zum Ende der letzten Sendung,
also nicht der jetzt letzten Sendung, sondern der letzten Sendung, die wir zu diesem Thema gemacht haben,
dass es eine Menge darüber zu erzählen gibt und dass wir da vielleicht auch mal später anknüpfen sollten.
Das teilten dann auch viele unserer Hörerinnen und Hörer dieses Gefühl und dann machen wir das halt einfach mal.
Sprich, heute geht es ein weiteres Mal um die Wüstenforschung und ein weiteres Mal begrüße ich dazu meinen Gesprächspartner,
nämlich Stefan Kröpelin.
Hallo.
Hallo und schönen guten Tag, ja schön, dass wir hier noch eine zweite Runde durchziehen können.
Sprich, wer jetzt hier frisch einsteigt, möchte wahrscheinlich wirklich nochmal auf Pause drücken und sich die ersten zwei Stunden,
die wir miteinander gesprochen haben, mal anhören, denn da sprechen wir viel über Ihre persönliche Geschichte.
Wie es überhaupt dazu kam, sich mit dem Thema Wüste zu beschäftigen.
Was so der Expeditionsalltag ist, den man so durchlebt, wenn man in die Wüste ziehen möchte.
Auch was es für Rahmenbedingungen gibt politischer, organisatorischer Natur.
Und wir haben natürlich auch ein paar Forschungsaspekte schon angesprochen, was man zum Beispiel an der Sahara in punkto Klimawandel ablesen kann,
war so ein Thema etc.
Aber das wollen wir jetzt alles nochmal ein wenig genauer beleuchten und vertiefen.
Und kehren von daher jetzt zurück in die Sahara.
Ja, Stefan Kröpelin, Geowissenschaftler, sage ich nochmal, nicht wahr, Geologe, Klimawissenschaftler.
Ich weiß nicht, beschreibt es das ausreichend?
Ja, vielleicht kann man noch anfügen Geoarchäologe, da es eben halt eine große Überlappung gibt mit der Archäologie.
Ja.
Ja Geoarchäologie und überhaupt ist mir eins so ein bisschen klar geworden, nämlich dass die Wüstenforschung insofern ein wenig anders ist
als andere Forschungsbereiche, weil üblicherweise haben Forscher und Wissenschaftler halt so ihren Fokus
und dann nehmen die sich dieses Themas an und in der Regel ist das Objekt mehr oder weniger direkt beobachtbar.
Man kann sich dann halt dem einfach zuwenden, muss vielleicht einen gewissen Aufwand treiben.
Bei der Wüstenforschung habe ich so mehr das Gefühl gehabt, das ist so ein bisschen mehr so der Lieferservice auch für andere Bereiche,
weil eben die Sahara so unfassbar unerreichbar ist.
Man denkt sich immer so, naja wieso ist doch hier gleich um die Ecke, kann man ja hinfliegen.
Wir haben schon drüber gesprochen und werden auch nochmal drüber sprechen, was für ein Aufwand das ist, dort zu sein.
Dort gibt es keine Infrastruktur, die Wetterbedingungen sind extrem, man muss alles mitnehmen, was man eben braucht für viele Leute
über einen sehr langen Zeitraum, die Expeditionen sind auch sehr sehr sehr lange, weil alleine schon die Vorbereitung so lange dauert,
damit es sich überhaupt lohnt, muss man eben auch entsprechend lange bleiben, das bläht den ganzen Apparat
und die ganzen Vorbereitungskosten dann natürlich auch nochmal enorm auf.
Aber am Ende ist man halt dort, sammelt quasi alles ein, was dort ist.
Und man kann sich das ja auch nicht aussuchen, sondern wo auch immer man hinkommt, man findet das eine oder man findet das andere,
das bringt man dann am Ende wieder mit zurück und dann können andere Wissenschaften und Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
überhaupt erst mal dieses Material sehen und sich neue Fragen stellen, weil sie ja vorher gar nicht wissen konnten,
was denn da alles so auf einen zukommt.
Von daher ist das mal eine ganz interessante interdisziplinäre Kombination.
Trifft es das?
Ja, das mit dem Lieferservice ist ein sehr guter Gedanke und das zeigt, dass man eigentlich nie genug Proben nehmen kann
in diese entlegenen Regionen, denn früher oder später wird sich immer irgendein Interessent finden.
Und dass man sich also bloß halt möglichst nie auf sein eigenes Fachgebiet beschränkt, sondern eben halt alles mitnimmt,
was man fassen kann und das hat sich ja schon oft herausgestellt, dass Proben, die man genommen hat,
wo man dachte, mein Gott wird nie jemand anschauen, dass sich da dann plötzlich großes Interesse entwickelt hat international
von Spezialisten aus allen Gebieten.
Und das mit dem Lieferservice ist sehr wichtig und es ist wichtig, die Proben zu haben, egal wann sie bearbeitet werden.
Natürlich ist es schön, wenn sie gleich nach Rückkehr bearbeiten, ausgewertet und veröffentlicht werden,
das ist aber halt meistens wegen mangelnder Finanzierung von den entsprechenden Stellen oder Doktorandenstellen nicht möglich, leider leider.
Aber irgendwann mal 50 Jahre später wird sich jemand auf die verbliebenen Proben stürzen und daraus was machen.
Und Lieferservice das werde ich mir merken.
Ich würde ganz gerne nochmal kurz beschreiben, worüber wir genau reden.
Weil Wüstenforschung, darüber hatten wir ja letztes Mal gesprochen, kann man natürlich sehr allgemein ansehen,
aber Ihr Fokus ist ja ganz klar der der Sahara.
Es gibt auch noch andere Wüsten, die ihre eigenen Kriterien mit sich bringen, die auch eine extreme Trockenheit haben,
Atacama-Wüste natürlich in Südamerika ist da zu nennen.
Es gibt natürlich auch große Wüstengebiete in China.
Ich weiß gar nicht, Wüste Gobi etc..
Waren Sie da eigentlich mal?
Genau.
Am Rand in der Gobi war ich.
Also ich war in den meisten warmen Wüsten auf der Erde, habe die also bereist, aber wie gesagt, der Schwerpunkt in der Ostsahara,
die halt wirklich bis heute der unerforschteste und lebloseste Teile aller Wüsten, zumindest aller Warmwüsten,
ich würde auch sagen, aller Wüsten global, je nach Definition.
Das ist also ein Gebiet, diese zwei Millionen Quadratkilometer, sechsfache Größe der Bundesrepublik,
das reicht noch für unzählige Leben, Forscherleben, um da nur einigermaßen den Wissensstand zu erzeugen, der aus anderen Wüsten schon längst bekannt ist.
Aber konkret reden wir eigentlich über die Ostsahara, also den Bereich, der sich vom – ich lasse mich gerne korrigieren –
vom Sudan bis zum Tschad, aber auch Niger noch erstreckt?
Nein, das nicht mehr, Ostsahara ist natürlich auch eine Definitionssache wie alles, aber im weitesten Sinne kann man auch sagen,
dass Teile des Tschads, wo ich arbeite, im Tibesti, dass es schon eher zur Zentralsahara gehört, aber entscheidend ist eben die sogenannte
historisch genannte libysche Wüste, also seit der Römischen Zeit, seit der Geschichtsschreibung
und die umfasst eben praktisch den östlichen Teil Libyens, den westlichen Teil Ägyptens, den nordwestlichen Teil des Sudans und den nordöstlichen Teil des Tschad.
Dieses vier-Länder-Gebiet und das ist eben der heute trockenste Raum der Erde, wo eben im langjährigen Mittel, soweit man das überhaupt weiß,
mangels Klimastationen, eben weniger als zwei Millimeter Niederschlag pro Jahr fallen, gegen eine Verdunstung von tausend Millimetern
und damit ist es eben ein hyperarider Raum, der halt ein ideales Forschungslabor darstellt, um zu sehen, war der immer so hyperarid
und wenn nicht, wie lange und wie war der in der Zeit der grünen Sahara ausgebildet?
Und das sind eben Bedingungen, die man eigentlich in keiner anderen Wüste der Erde in dieser Weise hat,
da sie entweder zu nahe an den Meeren liegen, wie die Atacama, die ja eigentlich nur ein Handtuch ist, ein langes Handtuch,
aber ein sehr schmales winziges Handtuch, also von der Gesamtgröße her bedingt durch den Atlantik, also wo viele Einflussmöglichkeiten sind
oder andere Wüsten, wie, sagen wir mal, die Namib, die halt einfach nicht diese Vielfalt und vor allem diese Größe bieten.
Wie gesagt, man darf nie vergessen, dass die gesamte Sahara eben größer ist als die USA und dass man deswegen ja gar nicht von der Sahara reden kann,
sondern von vielen Saharas, da ist ein riesiger Unterschied zwischen der westlichen Sahara, der zentralen und der östlichen Sahara
oder der nördlichen Sahara und der südlichen Sahara und das sind eben riesige Unterschiede und die kann man dort eben ganz besonders gut vergleichen,
einfach durch diese riesigen Distanzen, also West-Ost über 5.000 Kilometer und Nord-Süd über 2.000 Kilometer
und das ist eben die Besonderheit, die eben gerade diesen östlichen Teil so interessant machen.
Wenn ich so mal ganz dezent vom Satelliten quasi nach unten blicke, mir also anschaue, was heutzutage so an Kartenmaterial online verfügbar ist
und mir diesen Bereich anschaue, dann fällt schon so auf, dass irgendwie im Tschad am meisten los ist.
Also da gibt es sozusagen nochmal eine Menge Diversität, unter anderem gibt es ja ein riesiges Gebirge im Norden des Tschad,
was eben Teil der Sahara ist, ich glaube, das ist fast so groß wie die Alpen?
Ja, also ja auf jeden Fall.
3.400 …
Also ist natürlich auch wieder Definition, ob man jetzt die gesamten Alpen geologisch sieht.
Ja, ich meine von der Höhe her.
Was aber von der Höhe fast so hoch, also über 3.400 Meter und das Tibesti eben ist das größte und höchste Gebirge der gesamten Sahara,
also mit den höchsten Bergen, die halt Vulkane sind, über 3.400 Meter groß, mit riesigen Kratern, riesigen Calderen.
Also die größten Calderen, die es weltweit gibt …
Was sind Calderen?
Calderen sind meistens Einsturzkrater vulkanischen Ursprungs.
Es gibt auch Impact-Strukturen, eben von Meteoriten-Einschlägen, von denen es auch dort welche gibt, auch im Vorland des Tibesti,
die auch zu den größten der Erde gehören, aber im Wesentlichen ist es ein vulkanisches Gebirge in dem oberen Teil
und von einer Fläche von über 100.000 Quadratkilometern, was bis heute nur ansatzweise punktuell erforscht ist bis heute.
Und deswegen natürlich eine Herausforderung ist, wenn an in die letzten kaum oder nicht erforschten Gebiete geht.
Da ist ein Großteil dieser riesigen Calderen oder Krater hat noch nie jemand eine Probe genommen und das bis heute,
wo man inzwischen ja von 500 Millionen Kilometern entfernten Meteoriten schon Proben untersucht hat, das ist schon erstaunlich.
Ja. Wie muss man sich das Klima oben auf diesen Bergen vorstellen?
Also ist es da auch noch heiß, oder wird es dann da auch schon wieder angenehm kühl?
Also je nachdem, es kann sehr kalt werden.
So kalt haben wir es nicht erlebt, aber es gibt also Berichte von den wenigen militärgeografischen Expeditionen in den 30er Jahren,
die Temperaturen von unter Minus 15 Grad hatten, was ja gar nicht so schlimm ist, das Schlimme sind halt diese starken Winde,
die dann durch den Abkühlungsfaktor, den Chill-Faktor eben die empfundenen Temperaturen noch viel weiter absenken,
wo man sich wirklich also totfrieren kann in kürzester Zeit, wenn man nicht entsprechende Kleidung besitzt und Schlafsäcke.
auf anderen, dem zweithöchsten Berg des Tibesti und damit ja zweithöchsten Berg der Sahara,
haben wir auch da mit über 30 Kilogramm schweren Rücksäcken die dicksten Schlafsäcke hochgeschleppt,
um oben dann zu merken, es ist gar nicht so kalt und deswegen, weil dieser zweithöchste Berg, der Pick Toussidé eben noch vulkanisch aktiv ist
und das eben durch die Erdwärme, die nach oben dringt, es dann richtig angenehme Temperaturen hat, solange man am Boden liegt und so weiter.
Ist also noch längst nicht vulkanisch inaktiv, es ist nicht so aktiv wie Hawaii, aber sonst gibt es schon viele Ähnlichkeiten.
Aber generell ist es ein extrem zerklüftetes Gebirge, wo noch nicht mal Einheimische jemals waren
und wir hatten auf einer Expedition waren wir quasi die erste wissenschaftliche Expedition, die diesen Punkt, dieses Herz des Tibesti,
das sogenannte Tio Rocko-Massiv eben überhaupt erreicht haben und da reingekommen sind und ein paar Proben nehmen konnten.
Und das zeigt eben einfach halt, dass dort noch unheimlich viel zu holen ist und ich hoffe, dass das irgendwann kommen wird.
Ja, Sie hatten sich ja in der letzten Sendung schon ein bisschen beunruhigt gezeigt, ob denn der passende Nachwuchs überhaupt existiert.
Das lässt sich natürlich jetzt nicht abschätzen, aber am Ende gab es ja auch immer schon so einen Druck, glaube ich, in der Menschheit,
dass so die wirklich noch unerforschten Gebiete dann auch so einen gewissen Sog entfalten dann irgendwann.
Weil man war dann irgendwann mal so die Meere, werden jetzt im zunehmendem Maße auch untersucht.
Antarktis kennt man auch in zunehmendem Maße, ich denke, da wird es dann zwangsläufig irgendwann nochmal auf die Wüste hinauslaufen,
insbesondere wenn man sieht, was dort alles zu holen ist.
Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, dass für die Marineforschung und die Eiskernforschung unvergleichlich höhere Beträge zur verfügung stehen.
Die sind also, ich weiß nicht, ein Faktor von hundert oder noch höher liegend und da kann man natürlich viel mehr machen
und diese Arbeit in der Sahara ist natürlich vor allem eben durch die Sicherheitssituation, die sich ja seit zehn Jahren extrem verschlechtert hat,
wieder immer mehr abgeschottet.
Und ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich hätte eigentlich diesen heutigen Termin absagen müssen, weil ich normalerweise jetzt schon auf dem Weg in den Nord-Tschad wäre,
und diese Mission ist auch ganz kurzfristig vor wenigen Tagen wegen der Corona-bedingten Einreisestopps unmöglich geworden
und deswegen sitze ich jetzt auch hier, sonst hätte ich die Gelegenheit gehabt, noch einmal jetzt in diese tollen Regionen zu kommen.
Also jetzt haben wir sozusagen diesen Bereich mal abgesteckt.
Ich traue mich gar nicht zu fragen, aber wenn man jetzt mal sagt, okay es ist jetzt schwierig, hundert Prozent zu bilden, aber nur mal so für das Gefühl,
wieviel dieser Fläche, die man so theoretisch hätte schon mal bereisen können, ist denn von Menschen überhaupt schon mal bereist worden?
Also im Sinne von jetzt erforscht worden?
Ist das so im Bereich von 0,0001 Prozent oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen, wie wenig dort überhaupt schon mal nachgeschaut wurde?
Ja, das kommt natürlich drauf an, wenn man jetzt sagt, erforscht ist, wenn man eben mit dem Flugzeug rüberfliegt und da Untersuchungen macht,
zum Beispiel um Erdöl zu finden, dann sind schon große Areale abgeflogen.
Es gibt auch gerade in dem Teil, der früher zur französischen Kolonialmacht gehört hat, die sind auch zum Teil relativ gut kartiert,
wogegen es zum Beispiel in der Ostsahara ja im Grunde keine verfügbaren Karten hatte.
Wir mussten die ersten Karten Ende der 70er/Anfang der 80er erst selbst erstellen auf der Basis der damals ja aufkommenden,
noch sehr schlechten Satellitenaufnahmen und so weiter.
Wenn man, sagen wir mal, Standards anlegt von egal welchem Ort, sagen wir mal in Deutschland, dann sind es wirklich nur 0,000
und man muss sich überlegen, dass jede Ausgrabung, wo man hier an einem Platz, wo Jahre, Jahrzehnte lang ausgegraben wird
und dort sind es dann bei Grabungen vielleicht mal ein paar Tage mit wenigen Leuten, dann sind es bis heute fast überall nur Nadelstiche im Grunde,
wenn man das eben vergleicht, zum Beispiel die Forschung, die in USA getan ist, vergleichbar mit der gleichgroßen Sahara,
dann geht das gegen nichts.
Umgekehrt ist natürlich der große Vorteil, dadurch dass die Sahara so ein relativ homogener Raum ist, eben so ein ideales Forschungslabor,
was den Drittel eines ganzen Kontinents einnimmt, sind natürlich viele Ergebnisse, die man an diesen Nadelstichen findet,
auch übertragbar auf viel größere Areale.
Das heißt, das Klima ist relativ einheitlich, ist sehr verschieden zwischen der viel feuchteren West-Sahara
und der hyper-extremen Ost-Sahara, aber es ist natürlich überall beherrscht durch die Passatwinde.
Es ist überall charakterisiert durch diese Trockenheit und so weiter, und dadurch kann man eben durch geologische Funde,
durch archäologische Funde, durch biologische Funde und so weiter dann auch immer Rückschlüsse auf größere Areale treffen,
die zum Beispiel jetzt, sagen wir mal, gehen wir in die Schweiz, viel schwieriger sind, denn dort ist es eben in jedem kleinen Tälchen ein bisschen anders.
Und die Untersuchung eines Sees, die ist nicht übertragbar auf einen See, der nur zehn Kilometer entfernt ist, aber unter anderen Rahmenbedingungen,
etwas höher, etwas tiefer, stärker bewaldet außenrum und so weiter.
Dagegen wenn man jetzt einen Bohrkern aus der Sahara hat, zum Glück unser Bohrkern in dem Yoa-See, in den Ounianga-Seen im Nord-Tschad,
der ist übertragbar auf riesige Areale.
Und das könnte man eben meistens in jedem anderen Ort in den USA oder in Europa nicht so machen.
Jetzt würde ich ganz gerne mal auf so eine Expedition gehen, um vielleicht mal so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Wir hatten letztes Mal schon viel darüber gesprochen, welchen Aufwand es braucht und auch teilweise was alles so lustiges schiefgehen kann.
Ja, man hat also eine, ich weiß nicht, was würden Sie sagen, was so eine durchschnittliche Personalbesetzung einer Expedition ist, 20-30 Leute?
Nein, so viele nicht.
Die allerallergrößten, also sagen wir mal, es ist normalerweise, wenn man jetzt von den Forschern ausgeht, das sind so fünf bis maximal 20,
aber meistens 5-15 und so diese kleineren Teams sind meistens effizienter, weil je mehr man ist, desto einen größeren logistischen Aufwand,
desto mehr Fahrzeuge, desto mehr mechanische und logistische Probleme gibt es und gruppendynamische und und und,
deswegen sind also so Gruppen von fünf eigentlich mit drei-vier Fahrzeugen ideal.
Also fünf Leute nur?
Fünf Wissenschaftler insgesamt.
Wissenschaftler, aber da kommen dann noch andere Leute dazu?
Da kommen eventuell Mechaniker mit, wenn man Glück hat, in manchen Ländern wie im Tschad, den Luxus zu haben,
einen Koch zu haben, der einem natürlich unglaublich viel Zeit erspart, weil man nicht alles selbst machen muss und so weiter.
Dann ist ein Platz weg und in manchen Ländern hat man dann sogar auch Fahrer dabei und so weiter, es gehen immer mehrere Plätze mit.
Dann hat man ja immer mindestens einen, wenn nicht zwei, Kollegen, Studenten aus den Gastländern mit dabei,
die also halt, sagen wir mal, zum Teil zum ersten mal dort hinkommen und zum Teil ja dann auch später was forschungsmäßig auswerten,
aber das sind diese Plätze, die aus Deutschland oder von Europa finanzierten Forschungsprojekten, sind es meistens nur so fünf Forscher.
Und da habe ich halt immer drauf geachtet, dass sie halt aus möglichst verschiedenen Disziplinen sind.
Nicht nur Geologen und nicht nur Archäologen, nicht nur Paläoökologen und so weiter oder nur Meteoritenforscher und so weiter,
sondern dass man da halt möglichst ein breites Spektrum hat, wenn man an diese Orte kommt, wo wirklich oft noch nie jemand gewesen ist,
das wäre dann schade, wenn man dort nur die Gesteine und die Ablagerungen untersucht.
Okay, fünf bis zehn Leute, so dass man mal so eine Größenordnung im Kopf hat, was da für eine Truppe ist und dann ist man mit vier-fünf Fahrzeugen unterwegs.
Genau oder auch mehr, wenn man mehr Monate unterwegs ist und wohin man kommt.
Na gut, dann braucht man mehr als fünf Leute.
Dann braucht man einen LKW.
Okay. Jetzt ist es eine lange Anreise, man kommt dann irgendwann an im Sinne von, man ist quasi erst mal irgendwo, wo dann schon nichts mehr ist.
Also das letzte Dorf ist lange zurück, man ist vielleicht zwei-drei Tage schon reingefahren.
Im Prinzip muss ja eigentlich jeder Tag genutzt werden.
Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt haben wir diesen und diesen Breitengrad überschritten, jetzt können wir mal loslegen,
sondern eigentlich ist ja in dem Moment, wo die Zivilisation Abschied nimmt, wird es schon interessant.
Jetzt haben schon gehört letztes Mal, es wird im Freien übernachtet, weil es einfach praktischer ist.
Stelle ich mir irre vor.
Man wacht auf, wie beginnt so ein Tag, so ein Forschungstag?
Also der geht meist also damit los, dass also schon bevor die Sonne aufgeht es heller wird.
Man wacht auf, man geht ja normalerweise auch früher schlafen als bei uns, da es ja normalerweise auch immer so um 18 Uhr rum langsam dunkel wird.
Und je nach Mond und Sternen kann es extrem dunkel sein und da kann man dann nicht allzu viel machen
und dadurch wacht man natürlich auch so mit dem ersten Tageslicht auf.
Man steht auf, man klappt seinen Schlafsack zusammen, man packt seinen Seesack, alles rein.
Man geht zum Camp, wo man sich dann entweder selbst oder wenn man eben das Glück hat, einen Koch zu haben wie im Tschad,
ist dann schon der Tee fertig.
Wir essen natürlich am Boden auf einer Matte und dann frühstückt man eben, redet und dann geht es los.
Dann geht es entweder, wenn man irgendwelche Möglichkeiten hat, an diesem Ort zu arbeiten, dann geht man zu Fuß hin
oder man fährt mit dem Auto hin oder man fährt weiter, wenn man noch nicht angekommen ist und dann arbeitet man
oder fährt man den ganzen Tag, bis auf eine kurze Mittagspause, wo man sich halt in den meist nicht vorhandenen Schatten legt
und dann halt bisschen Müsli ist oder irgendwas oder einen Thunfisch mit Konservenbrot und dann geht es am Nachmittag weiter.
Geht man jetzt sozusagen bewusst auf die Suche?
Also zieht man einfach mal los und schreitet quasi die ganze Umgebung ab oder stößt man sowieso am laufenden Meter auf irgendwas?
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also die Zeit haben wir natürlich nicht, so schön es wäre, irgendwo hinzufahren und dann tagelang rumlaufen.
Was manchmal so Wüstenamateure, die ja oft die tollsten Funde machen, machen, die gehen wohin, gehen alleine oder mit einem Kamel tagelang.
Das habe ich mir immer geträumt, ist kaum passiert, wenn man also mit halt Teams unterwegs ist.
Aber es ist natürlich eine Kombination.
Es ist einmal die Vorbereitung, dass man also zum Beispiel jetzt guckt auf Satellitenbildern, die heute extrem gut sind.
Von solchen Bildern, wie man sie jetzt in GoogleEarth hat, hätte man ja nicht träumen können vor 30-40 Jahren.
Nicht in den entferntesten Vorstellungen, dass man dann eben guckt, wo könnte ein See Existenz haben?
Wo sieht man Spuren auf ehemalige Flusssysteme oder Wadi-Systeme.
Und in extremen Fällen kann man sogar schon eben aus Satellitenbildern Hinweise finden,
wo könnte es zum Beispiel im Umfeld dieser ehemaligen längst ausgetrockneten Seen auch archäologische Fundplätze finden.
Aber es ist gleichzeitig natürlich, man kann natürlich nicht alles sehen, außer von den besten Satellitenbildern, ist auch einfach,
man fährt und manchmal durch einen Zufall, man hat eine Reifenpanne und solange irgendjemand die Reifen wechselt, läuft man ein bisschen rum
und findet die tollsten Plätze.
Also es ist eine Kombination aus einmal Vorbereitung, von Zufallsfunden und natürlich Erfahrung.
Wenn man also wie ich 40 Jahre lang jedes Jahr monatelang in die Sahara fährt, dann entwickelt man ein Gefühl,
dass man manchmal sagen kann, da hinten dieser Felsen, ich wette sonst was, dass es dort Felsbilder gibt oder dass es dort einen interessanten prähistorischen Siedlungsplatz gibt
oder dass es was anderes gibt, da man sich natürlich reinversetzen kann in die früheren Bewohner, für die solche Landmarken,
solche herausragenden Felsen, die ja manchmal die tollsten Formen einnehmen, von Elefanten bis Pyramiden bis alle Arten von Tieren und so weiter,
die haben natürlich auch schon die prähistorischen Menschen, die eben grob vor 5000-10000 Jahren in der Ost-Sahara gelebt haben,
fast überall, auch angezogen und das waren dann bevorzugte Siedlungsplätze, wo man dann auch hohe Chancen hat,
eben zum Beispiel Felsbilder zu finden.
Und davor sind dann häufig, da ja Menschen immer Wasser brauchten, auch meistens in der Nähe befindliche ehemalige Wasserquellen gewesen.
Also halt entweder temporäre Seen, so Regentümpel, manchmal auch permanente Seen, weiter im Süden oder eben Quellaustritte,
die damals waren, als es noch mehr geregnet hat und so weiter.
Und dann hat man so ein gewisses Ensemble, was man dann immer wieder finden kann, aber ich bin sicher, dass wir die besten Plätze
auch nach 40 Jahren Großforschungsprogrammen noch nicht gefunden haben, dass die noch schlummern
und man sieht, was allein in den letzten zehn Jahren an neuen Felsbildfunden in den Regionen, wo man eben für eine gewisse Zeit hinkommt,
wie jetzt Nordtschad gefunden hat, das hätte sich auch vor 50 Jahren niemand träumen lassen können.
Also es ist noch unendlich viel zu tun, bloß die Rahmenbedingungen werden halt immer schlechter.
Felsbilder meint vermutlich quasi was man so als Höhlenmalerei bezeichnen würde, nur mangels Höhlen sind es halt hier die Felsbilder.
Es gibt auch Höhlen, aber es sind halt meistens so Überhänge, Felsabris nennt man sie, so Felsüberhänge,
aber es gibt natürlich auch Höhlen, wo auch Felsbilder drin sind, aber halt nicht wie in Lascaux.
Aber bleiben wir doch mal bei diesen Felsbildern.
Wie oft findet man so was?
Ist das irgendwie selten, kommt häufig vor?
Also in manchen…
In Relation zu allem anderen was man findet, meine ich.
Also in manchen Regionen, zum Beispiel wie im Ennedi-Plateau im Nordosten des Tschad, was ja auch Louvre der Steinzeit genannt wurde,
oder auch in Teilen des Tibesti, da findet man eigentlich überall Felsbilder.
Das können einfache Gravierungen sein, das können die spektakulärsten metergroßen …
Was heißt überall?
An jedem Stein, der rumliegt oder was?
Nein, nicht an jedem Stein, aber man geht zum Beispiel jetzt in irgendsoein Sandstein-Gebiet rein und dann,
wenn man dann auf der windabgewandten Seite, weil auf denen, die zum Wind hin stehen, ist natürlich häufig alles abgetragen,
wenn man sich überlegt…
Kommt der Wind immer aus derselben Seite?
Ja, von tausend … Passatwinde sind sehr stabil, die kommen halt meistens aus nordnordöstlicher Richtung,
und dadurch, wenn da jetzt schon, wenn man so will, Millionen oder hunderttausende von Sandstürmen in den letzten 5.000 Jahren drüber gegangen sind,
da wird natürlich alles abgeschmirgelt wie ein Sandstrahlgebläse.
Heißt, man muss schon da gucken, wo sie ein bisschen geschützt sind und das sind eben meistens die Felsüberhänge oder die Rückseiten,
die Leeseiten von solchen Sandsteinpfeilern oder Schichtstufen und so weiter.
Und da, wenn man genau guckt, findet man, wie gesagt, immer was.
Das können kleine Gravierungen sein, ganz primitiv, fast wie von Kindern rein gravierte, Kinder könnten das kaum machen,
weil das sehr hart Fels meistens ist, einfache Darstellung von irgendwelchen Gazellen, aber das können auch 10-20 Meter lange riesige,
also Felsbildpanels sein mit unzähligen Details und dem Extrem, wie dieser eine herausragende einzigartige Platz in Südost-Ägypten,
wo rund 10.000 Darstellungen sind an einer einzigen solchen Felsbildwand, die also von zwei Millimetern bis zwei Meter groß sind,
in Farben gemalt und die sich erhalten haben über die Jahrtausende.
Da gibt es ein Riesenspektrum.
Das gleiche ist im Tassili in Algerien zum Beispiel, weil es da auch sehr bekannt ist für die Felsbilder, wo man auch überall was findet.
Und ich denke, allein zum Beispiel im Ennedi und im Tibesti da sind noch sehr sehr viele Felsbildplätze zu finden.
Und die sind halt von herausragender Qualität, von erstaunlicher Farbigkeit und das Besondere bei den Felsbildern, die jetzt im Tschad sind,
also im Tibesti und im Ennedi ist eben, dass dort bis heute Menschen leben, weil es eben das Ennedi sich um ein Gunstgebiet handelt,
was bis heute noch ein bisschen Regen bekommt in den Sommermonaten.
Was für ein Gebiet?
Das Ennedi-Plateau.
Ein Gunst?
Ein Gunstgebiet, ein Gunstraum, also wo es noch regnet halt, wo es noch mehr regnet.
Wo günstigere Verhältnisse sind und wo der Grundwasserspiegel ziemlich nahe der Oberfläche ist.
Wo es günstig ist.
Und dann gibt es natürlich Pflanzen, solange die Wurzeln der Bäume, der Pflanzen ins Grundwasser können, ist es grün.
Das erzeugt natürlich wieder Lebewesen und so weiter.
Wenn dort Lebewesen kommen und Weiden entstehen, dann kommen auch Menschen oder bleiben dort.
Und die Besonderheit ist da eben jetzt speziell eben in diesem Ennedi-Plateau, was seit ein paar Jahren Welterbe ist,
dass dort man praktisch die Klima- und Umweltentwicklung und gleichzeitig die menschliche Besiedlung über einen Zeitraum von 10.000 Jahren verfolgen kann
und zum Teil im besten Fall, im idealen Fall an einer Felsbildwand.
Dass also dort zu acht Lagen übereinander angebracht sind, die von der Ergrünung der Sahara, sagen wir mal ganz grob, vor 10.000 Jahren,
um nicht ins Detail gehen zu müssen, begonnen hat, als es nur Wildtiere gab und zum Teil auch rundköpfige Menschen,
die ganz friedlich inmitten von Herden von Nashörnern sich bewegt haben, um ein Bild herauszugreifen.
Und dass dann später umringt, wo dann Tiere dargestellt sind, eben zum Beispiel wie Giraffen und Elefanten und sonst was.
Und dann kam eben eine spätere Periode und die war dominant, die war auch die längste eben, diese Zeit der Rinderhüter,
dass dort eben die Rinder, die wirklich ja majestätische Tiere sind mit langen Hörnern, hervorragend dargestellt sind und im Mittelpunkt stehen,
weil sie einfach eine riesige Bedeutung hatten in der Zeit und da gibt es auch noch viele detaillierte, fast fotografieähnliche Darstellungen
von den damaligen Lebensbedingungen, wie die Menschen gelebt haben, wie sie gekleidet waren, welche Tattoos sie hatten,
wie sie ihre Nahrung zubereitet haben, wie die Hütten ausgestattet waren und so weiter.
Das sind ganz tolle Bilder.
Und dann, als diese Zeit zu Ende ging, weil die Niederschläge zurückgingen, dann gab es eine Periode, die wahrscheinlich plus/minus
mit der Eisenzeit damals, die ja auch in der Region des Ennedis ihr Zentrum hatte, ob es das einzige Zentrum war, übersteigt jetzt mein Wissen,
aber es war sicher ein Zentrum der Eisenentstehung, da kam dann die Reiter…
Also Eisenzeit, wo die Menschen angefangen haben, Eisen zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Eisen zu verhütten und zu verwenden.
Es war ja vergleichsweise spät und in diesem vorchristlichen Jahrtausend.
Wahrscheinlich waren auch dominant eben Pferde, die konnten dort noch leben und wurden genutzt.
Und dann eben wurde es so trocken, dass dann man sich praktisch nur noch als einziges Verkehrsmittel die Kamele hatten,
also die Dromedare, de von den Persern eingeführt hatten, die aber, glaube ich, erst also vor maximal 2000 Jahren dann in den Tschad ihren Weg gefunden haben.
Ich glaube, erst ein paar hudert Jahre später wahrscheinlich und dann sind eben die oberste Schicht die Kamele
und wie gesagt, wenn man Glück hat manchmal, dann sind dadrüber noch Graffiti arabische, die 100-200 Jahre alt sind
und ganz oben ist dann ein Pickup, Toyota Pickup, machmal mit Maschinenpistolen hinten montiert, die stammt dann aus den 50er Jahren,
also die ersten Fahrzeuge hinkamen und die Einheimischen zum ersten Mal diese rollenden Fahrzeuge gesehen haben
das war erst in den 50er Jahren in den Regionen.
Und die gibt es dann auch in diesen Felsbildern?
Die sind dann die oberste Schicht von diesen acht Lagen.
Die muss man natürlich durch Bildbearbeitung rausziehen, das ist auch ein Ideal, manchmal sind es ein bisschen ältere Darstellungen an einer Stelle,
da sind Krokodile undeutlich und dann kommen die ganzen anderen Abfolgen, aber insgesamt hat man dort eine Abfolge, die nicht aufhört.
Dass zum Beispiel in Gilf el-Kebir, wo ja seit 5.000 Jahren im Grunde kein Mensch mehr leben konnte
und deswegen gibt es auch keine Felsbilder aus den letzten 5.000 Jahren.
Es gibt also keine Darstellung von Pferden, es gibt keine Darstellung von Kamelen, weil nicht mal die mehr dort hingekommen sind
oder von irgendeinem, die Nomaden malen da keine Felsbilder normalerweise, bis heute nicht, und dagegen eben im Nord-Tschad
da hat man das gesamte Holozän von der Ergrünung der Sahara bis zu ihrer Austrocknung, bis zum heutigen Tag, bis in die Gegenwart
und das ist eben eine ganz ganz große Besonderheit, die eine großartige Ergänzung ist zu den Ergebnissen aus der geologischen Klimageschichte
und aus den archäologischen Ausgrabungen, die dann natürlich viele zusätzliche Details liefern über die Lebensbedingungen,
über die ökonomischen Verhältnisse sozusagen der prähistorischen Siedler damals und das gibt eben so ein Gesamtbild,
was einfach unheimlich viel Spaß macht und wir haben zum Beispiel einen Artikel gemacht mit zwei Kollegen,
einen Archäologen, dem Heiko Riemer und einem Felsbildspezialisten, den Andras Zboray, wo wir praktisch unsere unterschiedlichen Ergebnisse zusammengelegt haben.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt die geologischen Ergebnisse zum Klimawandel der letzten 10.000 Jahre eingebracht hauptsächlich.
Der Andras Zboray hat die Felsbilder, eine Typologie der Felsbilder, also die unterschiedlich gemalt sind, mit unterschiedlichen Formen,
jede Periode oder jede Epoche hat ja ihre spezielle Kunst sozusagen.
Wie bei uns in Europa auch.
Wie bei uns genau, Andy Warhol gab es nicht vor 10.000 Jahren und so weiter.
Diese Typologie der Felsbilder und da ist eben der Heiko Riemer, der hat eben archäologische Ausgrabungen in der Umgebung,
alles im gleichen Großraum des Gilf el-Kebir, dieses großen Sandsteinplateaus im Südwesten Ägypten
und hat dann eben herausgefunden, welche Keramik sie hatten, welche Tiere sie gejagt haben, welche Tiere sie verspeist haben und so weiter
und wie die Bestattungen waren und so weiter.
Und diese Daten zusammen ergeben eben ein sehr lebendiges Bild und sie helfen bei einem der größten Rätsel der saharischen Felsbildkunst,
eben das Alter.
Die erste Frage jeden Vortrags ist, wie alt sind die, und es steht nicht dran.
Und man müsste sie zerstören, um sie zu datieren mit der C14-Methode zum Beispiel.
Müsste sie abkratzen, das ist ein Tabu, an das sich fast alle halten bis heute, aber eben über das zu sagen,
das heißt, wann waren Klimabedingungen, die diese bestimmten Tiere, die in den archäologischen Ausgrabungen kamen,
eben Lebensbedingungen geboten haben und gleichzeitig, wie haben die entsprechenden Maler die dann wiedergegeben in der Felsbildkunst.
Und so kommt man zu einem sehr schönen Gesamtbild, was in dieser Weise, also was es, sagen wir mal, vorsichtig gesagt, nicht oft gibt.
Sie meinten, Farbe wäre da drin, was kamen denn da für Farben zum Einsatz?
Also woraus wurden diese Farben denn gewonnen?
Also Farben, alle Saurier …
Aus dem Boden sozusagen?
Aus allen, es sind Mineralien, es sind Blut, es sind alles was es gibt Farben wirklich.
Da gibt es Spezialuntersuchungen, also wirklich von weiß bis schwarz, das gesamte Spektrum, die natürlich hauptsächlich aus Mineralien,
Pflanzenresten und Blut, aber da gibt es die wildesten Mischungen.
Und das Erstaunliche ist eben, dass diese Farben wirklich zum Teil noch in einer Pracht erhalten sind nach vielen tausend Jahren,
also bis 8.000 Jahren oder mehr, Farben muss man sich überlegen, und die trotz dieser extrem widrigen Bedingungen,
eben bei Sandstürmen, die halt irgendwann kommt Sand fast überall hin.
Viel Licht, viel UV-Strahlung.
Und UV-Strahlung, vor allem natürlich die Sonneneinstrahlung.
Es gibt welche, die jeden Tag stundenlang in der Sonne sind, das ist für mich das allergrößte Rätsel,
meistens sind sie natürlich schon geschützt.
Der Vorteil wiederum ist natürlich die absolute Trockenheit, dass es dort keine Feuchtigkeit gibt und dadurch halt keine Bakterien und sonstige,
die diese Pflanzen abbauen.
Also es ist erstaunlich, wenn man die mit modernen Industriefarben vergleicht, die ja meistens spätestens nach ein paar Jahrzehnten abplatzen
und das sind Naturfarben, die also 8.000 Jahre alt sind.
Das heißt, an dieser Stelle, um nochmal bei dem Lieferservicebild zu bleiben, liefert man quasi…
Ja, welche Wissenschaftsdisziplinen tangiert das denn jetzt sozusagen?
Das ist ja dann auch schon soziologische Wissenschaft an der Stelle.
Also es gibt, wie gesagt, ein sehr sehr weites Spektrum und da fallen mir jetzt nur ein paar Beispiele ein.
Zum Beispiel genetische Biologe jetzt Proben wollen von irgendwelchen Schneckenresten, die wir gefunden haben.
Sowohl die 10.000 Jahre alt sind, wie die sich in Isolation erhalten haben bis heute in diesen letzten verbleibenden Süßwasserseen der Sahara,
im nördlichen Tschad, in der Ounianga-Region.
Und das geht über Hinweise auf Lagerstätten, die wir halt nebenher, wir haben sie nie gesucht, aber wir haben eben Hinweise auf Gold,
Hinweise auf Uran, Hinweise auf Bauxit-Vorkommen und so weiter gefunden, an denen dann die jeweiligen Landesämter natürlich immer interessiert sind.
Die meisten von denen sind bis heute nicht gefördert, weil eben alles viel zu weit entfernt ist und sich das überhaupt nicht lohnt,
in diesen Gebieten eben die abzubauen.
Und das geht halt im Extrem hin bis halt wirklich in die Sprachwissenschaften zum Beispiel, die dann sagen, oh ihr habt da mal Seen gesehen
und ihr habt da ein Wadi, wie das große Wadi Howar, ehemals der größte Nebenfluss des Nils aus der Sahara, gefunden.
Und die dann darauf basierend, auf diesen früheren naturräumlichen Bedingungen, also auf der früheren Landschaft sozusagen geschlossen haben,
oh diese zwei Sprachgruppen, sagen wir mal, aus dem zentralen Afrika im heutigen Tschadsee-Bereich und dem Nil,
diese Sprachgruppen die hatten eine Verbindung und die müssen sich zu dieser Zeit ausgebreitet haben.
Also es geht wie gesagt da bis hinein so weit aus den Naturwissenschaften heraus.
Und auch zum Teil Anwendungen, an die man nie gedacht hätte, dass man zum Beispiel veröffentlicht jetzt eben über dieses Wadi Howar,
wo dann Zuschriften kamen von Spezialisten, die die alten historischen Quellen im alten griechischen neuinterpretiert haben und Herodot
und gesagt haben, oh könnten das in der damaligen Zeit dieses Wadi Howar die damaligen Menschen nicht als die Quellen des Nils betrachtet haben,
obwohl es ja nur ein Zufluss war und dass dann auf dieser Basis dann eben Neuübersetzungen entstanden sind, die dann viel mehr Sinn machen,
wo es dann Geschichten gab eben von den damaligen Siedlern, die dem Nil gefolgt sind und dann irgendwie zurückkamen ans Mittelmeer,
wo sich dann neue Erläuterungen gaben oder diesen alten See, den wir westnubischer Paläosee genannt, so also im Nordwest-Sudan,
dass es sich dabei um die Ptolemäischen Sümpfe der Cheloniden, der Schildkröten gehandelt haben muss.
Wir haben auch Wasserschildkröten gefunden, dass also praktisch so historische Übertragungen, die also durch halt mündliche Übertragungen
ja Jahrtausende gemacht haben, dass sie sie noch vom Ptolemäus oder von Herodot aufgeschrieben werden konnten,
aber da die eben einen wahren Grund haben und dass praktisch dann jetzt der geologische, archäologische Beweis erbrachte,
dass es diese Seen oder Flüsse tatsächlich gab.
Also der Einfluss ist auf jeden Fall sehr breit in andere Wissenschaftsbereiche und man kann es gar nicht so ohne Weiteres einschränken.
Aber ein klarer Schwerpunkt ist natürlich die Geologie und natürlich auch die Archäologie.
Was, um vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen auf den Tagesablauf zurückzukommen, das hatten wir streckenweise auch schon in der ersten Sendung angesprochen,
aber ich finde das nochmal ganz interessant, wenn man jetzt doch an so einem Ort ankommt und ich meine, man hat jetzt vielleicht keine Zeit rumzulaufen,
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, ich meine, man fährt ja nicht irgendwo hin, um dann gleich wieder weiter zu fahren,
sondern irgendwo muss man ja dann auch mal bleiben.
Also bleibt man nicht auch mal einen Tag an einem Ort?
Ja sicher.
Das meine ich doch.
Es gibt auch, wo man Tage oder Wochen bleiben muss.
Dann haben wir uns vielleicht missverstanden.
Genau, das heißt, dann verbringt man doch den Tag im Wesentlichen damit, auch wirklich mal diese Gebiete abzulaufen?
Genau, da gibt es dann den großen Unterschied, dass, sagen wir mal, die Geologen oder die Geowissenschaftler, auch die Geografen,
das sind eher Nomaden.
Das heißt normalerweise, man fährt wohin, man hat ein Unimog, an dem ein Bagger montiert ist und dann gräbt man ein zwei-drei Meter tiefes Loch,
springt rein, nimmt den auf, nimmt Proben, beschreibt ihn, sucht nach Holzkohle und dann das dauert ein-zwei Stunden und dann fährt man weiter.
Man sucht nach Holzkohle, warum?
Ja, um die zu datieren.
Denn heutzutage in der Wissenschaft kann man die tollsten Funde machen, wenn die nicht datierbar sind, wenn man nicht weiß,
die sind 5.000 Jahre alt oder 100.000 oder 500.000, dann interessiert das keinen.
Man braucht heute eine Chronologie und die kriegt man in den meisten Fällen über Datierungen von Holzkohle, die halt die besten Daten ergeben,
durch die Radiokarbondatierungsmethode.
Es gibt auch andere Datierungsmethoden, die etwas unsicherer sind und das beste sind halt die Ablagerungen, die wir in diesem Yoa-See haben,
die man abzählen kann, aber normalerweise ist datierbares Material sehr wichtig und da muss man eben dann geologische Aufschlüsse,
natürliche Aufschlüsse, das sind eben wirklich irgendwelche Wände, die durch einen späteren Bachlauf eingeschnitten wurden,
wo man dann nicht graben muss oder bohren muss, sondern die man halt wirklich untersuchen kann unter der Sonne,
die sind natürlich viel günstiger, aber um eben so datierbares Material zu finden, das ist meistens ziemlich aufwändig.
Ist denn da so viel Holzkohle im Boden in der Regel zu finden?
Natürlich nicht überall.
In manchen, also es gab ja immer Savannenfeuer, Buschfeuer, wo dann irgendwelche Holzkohleflitter, kleine Teile reingeweht wurden,
die man findet.
Sobald es irgendwo Wasser gab, saßen da auch Menschen, die haben natürlich Feuer gemacht und das wurde dann auch reingeweht.
Aber es gibt insgesamt sehr wenig, unterschiedlich, es gibt Gebiete, da findet man fast verkohlte Baumstämme eingebettet in solchen alten Sumpfablagerungen.
Das ist aber eher die Ausnahme.
Das ist dann ein Volltreffer sozusagen?
Das ist der Volltreffer, das ist dann schon zu viel des Guten.
Aber der Unterschied ist eben dagegen die Archäologen, deswegen die Frage, die Archäologen die brauchen Zeit.
Die brauchen für die kleinsten Ausgrabungen Tage bis Wochen und selbst dann haben sie oft nur ein paar Quadratmeter untersucht,
weil es einen unglaublich aufwendige Arbeit ist, Zentimeter für Zentimeter die Schichten abzutragen, zu dokumentieren, zu fotografieren,
einzumessen und so weiter, das ist sehr sehr sehr aufwendig.
Und deswegen ist es ein Unterschied, wenn man in geologischen Teams ist, dann ist man selten bei einer langen Bohrung,
wie in den Ounianga-Seen, da wo ich wirklich schon mehrfach wochenlang war, aber das ist die Ausnahme.
Es war meistens selten an einem Ort mehr als ein-zwei Tage.
Und dann hat man das im Kasten und man fährt weiter zum nächsten Profil, zum nächsten Baggerloch, zur nächsten Bohrung.
Die Archäologen wollen am liebsten, und müssen auch, am liebsten eben an einem Ort so lange wie möglich bleiben,
wenn der genug hergibt, auch wenn sie nur einen Bruchteil, Promille manchmal von archäologischen Plätzen ausgraben können.
Und die Zusammenarbeit ist dann eben das Tolle, dass eben die Archäologie die Präzession bringt und die Datenmenge über die damaligen Lebensbedingungen,
die eben dann Aussagen geben über die damalige Ökologie und die Geologen, die halt den großen Rahmen bringen über die Altersstellung,
über die Umweltbedingungen von geografischen Verhältnissen und so weiter.
Und das Zusammenspiel ist unheimlich fruchtbar, ganz fruchtbar, diese Geoarchäologie.
Problem ist natürlich im Gelände, dass die Geologen immer weiter wollen und die Archäologen wollen immer bleiben.
Und da einen Kompromiss zu finden, das geht manchmal so, dass man sich eben aufteilt und die Archäologen bleiben da,
während die Geowissenschaftler rumfahren, dann wieder zurückkommen und so weiter.
Also das ist dann eben der Abgleich immer, dass natürlich jede Forschungsrichtung seinen eigenen Zeitbedarf hat und seine eigene Präferenz hat,
Botaniker normalerweise sind auch ziemlich schnell, weil die nehmen Pflanzenproben, wenn es noch Pflanzen gibt natürlich nur in den wenigen Bereichen
oder im Tibesti-Gebirge und die sind auch immer relativ schnell fertig und wollen weiter.
Und die Archäologen sind sehr sesshaft, muss man auch so sein, sonst kann man diese Arbeit gar nicht durchführen
und die haben dann auch einen relativ regelmäßigen Lebenslauf, Tagesablauf, also frühstücken, zur Arbeit gehen, mittags zurück
Mittagspause machen, nachmittags wieder zur Arbeit gehen und das eben sieben Tage die Woche, auch wenn es Monate dauert.
Das ist regelmäßig.
Die Geowissenschaftler wollen halt immer in die Fläche gehen und so viele Vergleichsorte untersuchen, um eben zum Gesamtbild zu kommen
über dieses riesige Gebiet der Ostsahara, wie gesagt, Arbeitsgebiet ein-zwei Millionen Quadratkilometer, so viel kann man gar nicht rumfahren,
so viel Diesel hat man nicht.
Wie bestimmt man denn überhaupt die Route, die man jetzt fahren will?
Also wenn alles im Wesentlichen unerforscht ist, ist es dann irgendwie ein Würfelwurf und da steht dann die Gradzahl, die man jetzt abbiegt
oder hat man schon ein Ziel, was man sich irgendwie zufällig gesteckt hat oder sucht man sich halt das tatsächlich auf Satellitenbildern raus,
wo man schon immer mal hin wollte?
Nein, natürlich so geht es nicht, es hat natürlich immer Schwerpunkte, die man angeht.
Und es gab ja auch, als wir angefangen haben, oder als diese Forschung in der Ostsahara begonnen hat, Ende der 70er/Anfang der 80er,
gab es natürlich ein paar Pioniere schon, die dort in den 30/40er Jahren waren.
Ich erinnere nur an den berühmten englischen Patienten, Ladislaus Almásy, den es ja in Wirklichkeit gegeben hat,
der in diesen Regionen war und es gab Felsbildforscher wie Hans Rhotert, die in diesen Regionen waren
und die gaben dann natürlich Anhaltspunkte.
Die haben für die Zeit, für die damalige Zeit, schon unglaublich gute Arbeit gemacht, aber natürlich ohne irgendwelche moderne naturwissenschaftliche Methodik und so weiter
und das waren dann Regionen, wo man sagt, da wollen wir jetzt näher nachschauen.
Im Gilf Kebir in der Schwimmerhöhle oder im Wadi Howar, da war Frobenius mit seinen Expeditionen 33/34 mit Hans Rhotert,
aber die konnten nur ein paar Stunden verbringen, haben aber schon gesehen, das ist ein interessantes Gebiet, das könnte der gelbe Nil sein
und da sind wir hingefahren.
Wadi sind Flüsse?
Wadi sind Trockenflüsse, die nur zeitweilig fließen, eben einmal im Jahr, einmal alle paar Jahren,
in feuchteren Gebieten auch alle paar Wochen, alle paar Monate, sind also temporär fließende Flüsse
und deswegen nennt man sie auch Trockenflüsse, weil sie die allerallermeiste Zeit trocken liegen.
Und die sind halt typisch.
Permanente Flüsse wie den Nil gab es in der Sahara nie, denn die hätten ja permanent Wasser bekommen müssen
und das wären dann Fremdlingsflüsse gewesen, der Nil kriegt das meiste Wasser eben auch im äthiopischen Hochland,
weil es da über den Blauen Nil kommt und deswegen fließt.
Und ein Flusssystem, was in der Sahara liegt, das war praktisch nie permanent, nicht mal die Flüsse, die eben zum Beispiel in der Nordsahara von den Atlasgebirgen runtergeflossen sind,
auch die waren immer unterbrochen und deswegen also permanente Flüsse gab es auch in der Feuchtzeit nie.
Trotzdem sind diese Flussbetten interessante Orte, weil sie ja zumindest für die kurze Zeit, die sie Wasser getragen haben,
dann eben auch gleich die Sedimente ausgewaschen haben und von daher sehr viel besser lesbar sind, da muss man nicht so viel graben?
Genau, also man muss da schon graben.
Wenn man wo Wasser findet, dann unter dem Wasserboden, wenn man da ein paar Meter reingräbt,
kommt man meistens auf Feuchtigkeit, im besten Fall sogar auf das Grundwasser und das wussten natürlich die prähistorischen Menschen auch.
Und das machen sie ja bis heute.
Unter dem Flussboden?
Am Flussbett, was ja meistens aus Sand oder Kies besteht, wenn man das aufgräbt und das nicht längst ausgetrocknet ist,
dann findet man dort immer noch genug Wasser und damit auch eben Besiedlungsreste aus dieser Zeit.
Und noch interessanter sind natürlich immer die Seeablagerungen in den Seen, die es damals gab, die auch …
es gab in dem südlichen Teil, sagen wir mal, Nord-Sudan, gab es Seen oder natürlich im Nord-Tschad, die über Jahrtausende lang Wasser geführt haben.
Die Süßwasserseen waren, nicht Salzwasserseen wie heute wie fast alle verbleibenden Seen auf der ganzen Welt, das sind alles Salzseen,
weil sie sehr schnell versalzen durch die Anreicherung der im Wasser befindlichen Salze, so gering sie auch sind, aber er reichert sich an,
also jeder Süßwassersee wird ziemlich schnell innerhalb von Jahren zum Salzwassersee, mit der Ausnahme der Seen von Ounianga im Nord-Tschad,
aber das ist ein anderes Thema, und die sind natürlich noch viel bessere Sedimentfänger oder Sedimentfallen,
weil dort normalerweise, vor allem wenn es tiefe Seen waren, die Ablagerungen ja versunken sind und sich dann übereinander aufgeschichtet haben,
so dass man dort eben viel bessere geologische Informationen über die Entwicklung der Seen über die Klimaentwicklung finden kann
als in einem Wadi, weil da können tolle Ablagerungen abgelagert sein, aber dann kommt ein neuer Abfluss und der schwemmt das wieder alles weg
und dann kommt der Wind, bläst einen Großteil weg und dann kommt wieder ein Wasser und legt was ab,
das heißt, das sind viel schlechtere Klimaarchive, wie wir sagen, als eben die Ablagerungen an den Seen,
ob sie ausgetrocknet sind inzwischen oder seit Jahrtausenden oder ob sie noch existieren wie im Nord-Tschad.
Das heißt, das sind so die interessanten Orte, also unter anderem, das sind unter anderem interessante Orte, die man sich anschaut,
wir hatten ja vorhin schon so dieses, man schaut einfach mal in die Landschaft und sieht so, ach okay, ich finde diesen Fels cool,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das auch früher jemand cool fand, ist relativ hoch, da schaue ich mal nach.
Genau.
Dass da sozusagen eher was für die Archäologie, Flüsse, Seen etc. sind so interessante Orte für die Geologen.
Wo rennen denn dann die Botaniker hin oder was ist sozusagen potenziell auch noch für andere Wissenschaftsbereiche interessanter Ort?
Es ist eben mit der Botanik, das sind auch immer sehr angeregte Diskussionen mit den Botanikern und eben also einem Freund und langjährigen Kollegen,
dem Frank Darius, wenn ich sage, gut wir fahren jetzt hunderte Kilometer, ich sage mal, durch die ägyptische Wüste
und da war nicht ein Hauch von Vegetation.
Und dann kommt er und sagt, nein, also hier war ein winziges Pflänzchen oder hier ist eine Grünalge auf der Rückwand,
das heißt, es gibt Regionen, die absolut steril sind, wo wirklich nichts übrig ist, aber es gibt natürlich sobald irgendwo das Grundwasser noch bis heute näher ist,
das fossile Grundwasser, der Regen, der vor 10.000-5.000 Jahren gefallen ist, immer noch diese Grundwasserspeicher so hoch hält,
dass dort die Wurzeln rankommen, dann gibt es natürlich Pflanzen.
Es gibt auch manchmal, man fährt hundert Kilometer und man stößt auf einen einzelnen Baum, den man sich nicht erklären kann,
aber der dann wahrscheinlich durch ganz besondere Felsnischen im Untergrund mit zum Teil ja 50 Meter tiefen Wurzeln noch das Grundwasser erreicht
und dann da alleine rumsteht.
Also es gibt wirklich immer wieder, dass man sich fragt, wie kann das, wo kommt das Wasser hier in diesem praktisch regenlosen Gebiet
und zum Teil eben Sträucher und Bäume auch her.
Also das ist immer faszinierend, aber insgesamt ist es wirklich die trockenste Wüste, die Atacama-Wüste ist wesentlich,
da regnet es zwar genauso wenig oder manche behaupten, noch weniger, aber auf jeden Fall auch so gut wie nicht,
aber dort kommt natürlich die ganze Feuchte vom Humboldtstrom rüber vom Meer,
deswegen ist die Pflanzenwelt in der Atacama ja viel viel besser ausgeprägt als in der östlichen Sahara
und jetzt von Südwest-Ägypten ganz zu schweigen.
Das ist ja, sagen wir mal, nach unseren Maßstäben überhaupt keine Wüste, sondern ist eine Halbwüste,
sonst könnte sie auch nicht leben, die Wüste lebt und so weiter.
Also da muss man halt da genauer sagen, ab wieviel Millimeter Niederschlag und welcher Vegetation nennt man es überhaupt eine Wüste,
und Wüste wird es erst, wenn man nicht mehr von Strauch zu Strauch springen kann.
Und da gibt es auch etwas wissenschaftlichere…
Wenn man ins Gebirge geht, zum Beispiel ins Tibesti-Gebirge, der durch die Höhe noch viel mehr Regen erhält in der Höhe
und dort feuchter ist, dann gibt es natürlich sofort mehr Pflanzen, das ist ganz klar.
Und sobald man in die Flachländer geht, die weit entfernt ist, da wo man wirklich über hunderte Kilometer keinen Strauch und kein Gras findet.
So ein Baum mitten in der Wüste ist natürlich eine besondere Sicht.
Was man ja kennt sind die Klassiker, die Oase und die Fata Morgana, die einen da irgendwie hinführt.
Wie häufig sind denn diese Oasen eigentlich und wie kommt es denn zu diesen?
Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich jetzt eine falsche Vorstellung davon.
Nein.
Man denkt ja immer so, ja okay, erst mal 300 Kilometer gar nichts und dann mittendrin ist auf einmal alles grün, ganz so ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Aber das sind ja schon dann auch Ausnahmeorte.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also da gibt es natürlich auch große Unterschiede.
Also in der Ostsahara wiederum gibt es praktisch keine Oasen, also außerhalb dieser großen Oasendepression,
die ja westlich des Nils verläuft, die geht also praktisch Bahariya, Farafra, Dakhla und Kharga,
die eben so eine Oasensequenz haben, wo ja auch heute ziemlich viele Menschen leben, es wird auch das neue Tal genannt in Ägypten,
da gab es viele Pläne, da viele Menschen umzusiedeln, was ja zum Teil auch passiert ist, bis jetzt das Grundwasser langsam immer mehr ausgeht und so weiter.
Das ist also in tiefen Depressionen.
Die andere Oase ist die Kufra-Oase in Libyen, die südlichste Oase, die den Namen verdient,
die also die einzige größere Oase im südsüdöstlichen Libyen ist, wo auch relativ viele Menschen leben.
Also es sind Kleinstädte, aber immerhin und so weiter.
Und die können natürlich nur da entstehen, wo Wasser vorhanden ist und das ist eben das fossile Grundwasser,
was an manchen Stellen eben artesisch an die Oberfläche kommt.
Was heißt das?
Artesisch, da ist praktisch eine Deckschicht, die praktisch verhindert, dass das Grundwasser überall nach oben geht,
aber es gibt irgendwo eine Schwäche, geologische Schwächezone, eine Kluft, entlang derer das Wasser dann praktisch nach oben dringt,
zum Teil bis an die Oberfläche.
Und das ist eben vorhanden in den Oasen-Gebieten Ägyptens und eben in Kufra.
Sonst gibt es im Nordwest-Sudan praktisch zwei Oasen, im Grunde die den Namen verdienen.
Eine ist wahrscheinlich inzwischen ausgetrocknet, wo eben auch noch das Grundwasser aufgrund besonderer geologischen Gelegenheiten
bis nahe oder bis richtig an die Oberfläche kommen, aber alle Oasen sind praktisch dem Untergang geweiht.
Also einmal war die Sahara ja mal fast komplett grün.
Natürlich im Süden, Teil südlicher Hälfte, viel grüner als im nördlichen Teil, aber trotzdem.
Und dann haben sich halt immer mehr isolierte Seen und Oasen gebildet.
Und von diesen abertausenden von Oasen, die es noch vor 5.000 Jahren gegeben haben muss in der Sahara,
sind also wirklich nur noch ein paar Hand voll übrig und vor allem im östlichen trockenen Teil.
Und das ist einzig und allein durch das Grundwasser gemacht.
Man kann natürlich heute …
Also durch das fossile Grundwasser.
Fossile Grundwasser, es regnet nicht mehr.
Kein Grundwasser, wie man das hier kennt, was sich sozusagen permanent auch durch Regen wieder auffüllt,
sondern einfach Reservoire, die sich durch geologische Strukturen eben einfach mal so gebildet haben
und wenn da jetzt auch gerade, wie das ja, glaube ich, bei vielen Oasen der Fall ist, das dann auch noch aktiv rausgepumpt wird,
und dort Landwirtschaft zu betreiben.
Genau.
Dann ist natürlich irgendwann auch Schluss.
Genau, dann ist es ground water mining, dann nimmt man es wie Erdöl, kann man einmal fördern, dann ist es weg bis zur nächsten Feuchtzeit,
die ja normalerweise vielleicht erst in 50-60.000, 70.000 Jahre käme, warten wir mal ab, außer es geht doch schneller.
Und das ist natürlich die Gefahr, wenn man dann zu engmaschig das abpumpt, was gerade in Ägypten getan wurde, ja auch in Libyen,
dass dann sich Grundwasserabsenkungstrichter bilden, weil das Grundwasser ja nur sehr langsam nachfließt.
Das ist ja nicht wie ein Wasserhahn, sondern es fließt ja zum Teil mit Geschwindigkeiten im Extrem von wenigen Metern pro Jahr.
Das heißt, das nachfließende Grundwasser wird dann in diesen Grundwassertrichtern schnell abgesenkt und erlöscht dann
und dann lohnt es sich nicht mehr und deswegen sollte man eigentlich dieses fossile alte Regenwasser aus den Feuchtzeiten
vor 10.000, vor 100.000 Jahren, vor 200.000 Jahren eigentlich nur für die allerwichtigsten Anwendungen nutzen,
die dann wirklich auch ökonomischen Nutzen haben und nicht jetzt um Tomaten anzubauen, die dann meistens auf dem Transport nach Kairo sowieso kaputt gehen
oder alles mögliche.
Also sagen wir mal, das Grundwasser, die Grundwasserthematik ist eigentlich die allerwichtigste in diesen ja auch extrem bevölkerungsreichen Gebieten,
die eben halt Ägypten, ohne Wasser kann niemand leben und das Grundwasser kann man zwar kurzfristig fördern,
man muss aber wissen, nach ein paar Jahren, nach ein paar Jahrzehnten ist es aus, da halt praktisch reell nichts mehr nachgebildet wird.
Und das ist natürlich viel wichtiger als Erdöl noch in den ganzen Trockengebieten vom Atlantik bis nach Zentralasien.
Und die Fata Morgana gibt es die?
Die gibt es.
Also es gibt unterschiedliche.
Es gibt Fata Morganen, also normale, diese Luftspiegelungen, die findet man, wenn es heiß ist, jeden Tag überall,
wo praktisch so riesige, wenn man erst mal hinkommt, sieht aus wie Wasserflächen, die manchmal wirklich realistisch sind,
da sagt man, jetzt ist wirklich was und dann nähert man sich und sie verschwinden.
Die ganz besonderen, also im engeren Sinn die Fata Morganas, das sind die, wo es dann auch Luftspiegelungen gibt,
die durch bestimmte Verhältnisse da sind, da sie zum Beispiel wirklich eine echt vorhandene Oase irgendwie spiegelt in ein Gebiet,
wo es die gar nicht gibt, die wird praktisch so symmetrisch umgedreht und woanders hin projiziert oder erscheint so.
Die sind extrem selten, das ist mir also erst zwei-, drei-, viermal dass ich das gesehen habe.
Sonst aber diese normal als Wasserflächen erscheinenden, wo man dann denkt, wie Moses geht man durch das Rote Meer
und in Wirklichkeit sind es halt einfach die durch die Temperaturunterschiede gebildeten Spiegelflächen, die findet man sobald es heiß ist überall jeden Tag
und da kommt man sich wirklich vor wie, fährt man jetzt dauernd den ganzen Tag durch das Flachwasser, in extrem flachen Gebieten.
Vielleicht konnte Jesus ja gar nicht über Wasser gehen, sondern der ist über eine Fata Morgana gegangen.
Ja sicher, bin ich überzeugt davon, dass das …
Okay, also Luftspiegelung ist ja jetzt sozusagen nichts, was auf die Sahara beschränkt, nur kommt es dort halt relativ häufig vor,
eben durch diese großen Temperaturen.
Aber wie echt ist denn das?
Also wenn man jetzt sozusagen so eine gespiegelte Oase sieht, wie lange braucht man, bis man das checkt, dass es das nicht ist?
Also die wenigen Male, wo ich das selbst erlebt habe, das war wirklich, also unterschiedliche Dimensionen,
weil es hängt da wirklich von vielen Faktoren ab und so weiter, wo man wirklich bis zuletzt gedacht hat, Mensch da ist wirklich,
da stehen Palmen und alle möglichen Häuser und sonst was, bis man gemerkt hat, das ist es nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist extrem selten.
Und die anderen, da gewöhnt man sich schnell dran, weil man sieht dann mal ein Pferd oder man läuft und mit dem Auto geht es natürlich schneller,
und wenn man mit dem Auto fährt und dann denkt, da hinten vor diesem Felsen da ist ein See und dann kommt man hin und es ist kein See,
dann checkt man natürlich ziemlich schnell, dass es reine Spiegelungsphänomene sind und nirgends ein Tropfen Wasser ist.
Und das ist wie so ein Regenbogen, da kann man auch nicht am Anfang voran, der weicht immer weiter zurück
und das ist also immer wieder amüsant, aber es sind halt die meisten, die das erste Mal so was sehen, die sind schon immer sehr beeindruckt.
Das ist also schon ein Erlebnis, aber gewöhnt man sich natürlich sehr schnell dran.
Was wir am Rande auch angesprochen haben, aber jetzt liegt hier auch noch so ein Objekt auf dem Tisch,
deswegen will ich das auch nochmal ansprechen, die Sahara ist natürlich ein perfekter Ort, um Meteoriten zu finden,
die sich ja ohnehin am laufenden Meter in irgendeiner Form über der Erde abregnen.
Die allermeisten davon erreichen, wenn überhaupt, dann nur in kleinen Teilen die Oberfläche und alles, was natürlich im Ozean versinkt,
das ist dann halt erst mal weg.
Und was so in unseren Breiten da halt runterkommt, naja das steckt dann halt schnell mal im Matsch, ist irgendwo und fällt nicht weiter auf,
weil es eben so viele andere Dinge gibt, die ähnlich aussehen, nimmt das keiner wahr,
aber in der Sahara sieht das natürlich gleich ganz anders aus.
Das Meteoritenmaterial ist zwangsläufig immer schwarz, weil es eben durch den Eintritt an der Oberfläche so schwarz verbrennt quasi.
Ich sehe schon skeptische Blicke, es gibt auch Ausnahmen?
Also klar, wenn es lange rumliegt und vom Sand abgeschliffen ist, dann sieht es anders aus, richtig?
Ja, es gibt halt alles.
Und Wüsten sind ja wie eben halt zum Beispiel in der Antarktis oder so, das sind optisch reine Flächen, also diese Sand sheets in Ägypten,
die ja die Größe Bayerns haben zum Beispiel, wo wirklich eine absolut glatte Oberfläche aus festliegendem Sand
und jedes größere Objekt, was dort liegt, das muss entweder ein Meteorit sein oder vom Menschen dort hingebracht.
Also ein Artefakt, ob das jetzt ein Steinartefakt ist, ein Steinwerkzeug ist oder ein Stein, um Tiere zu fangen.
Warum ist das so glatt, was ist die geologische Erklärung dafür?
Das sind bestimmte geologische Flächen, das hängt natürlich ab davon, ob drunter jetzt ein flacher Sandstein ist,
wo sich der Sand erhalten hat.
Also Wanderdünen, eben die Barchane ziehen dann schon durch in verschiedenen vogelschwarmartigen Abfolgen und so weiter,
aber die Hauptfläche ist gerade, das liegt halt einfach an der strukturellen Geologie, wo kein Gebirge ist,
wo es wirklich flach ist und keine Schichtstufe ist, da bilden sich solche Flächen aus, der Wind spielt auch eine Rolle und das ist flach.
Und das heißt, alles was man findet, man fährt vom Auto, man kann ja 100 Meter, 200 Meter, bei guter Sicht auch noch weiter größere Objekte entdecken
und man fährt hin und entweder ist es meistens eine Hinterlassenschaft der Menschen, weil es kann ja dort nicht wie im Eis,
wenn da ein Fundplatz ist oder ein Meteorit liegt in der Antarktis und es ist mal im Sommer wärmer und dann heizt der sich schneller auf und versinkt im Eis,
dagegen an der Oberfläche auf dem Sand kann der nicht versinken, der könnte höchstens zugeschüttet werden durch eine Düne,
die dann irgendwann auch wieder weiterläuft, aber die bleibt da liegen, und dadurch ist es eben ein hervorragender Ort, um Meteoriten zu finden.
Und es gibt eben auch Meteoriten, natürlich die meisten, haben Sie völlig recht, das sind also Eisenmeteoriten,
die man zum Teil in großen Quantitäten findet, die schwarz sind, die entsprechende Erscheinungsform haben,
aber es gibt eben auch Marsmeteoriten, die eben viel schwerer zu identifizieren sind, weil sie eben so rötlich aussehen
und weil sie genauso aussehen wie jeder Stein, der auf der Oberfläche ist.
Das heißt, den würde man auf einer Sandstein-Hamada, auf so einer Sandsteinfelsfläche niemals identifizieren können,
aber wenn der natürlich in dem Sand liegt…
Es gibt auch in der Westsahara, ich habe da auch Einheimischen geholfen, die untersuchen zu lassen, weil die natürlich sehr wertvoll sind,
wenn Sie wirklich als Marsgestein identifiziert werden, dann hat die NASA da früher auch 20 Millionen für ein faustgroßes Stück gezahlt.
Und heute sind die Preise gefallen, aber immer noch, die sind dann wirklich sehr gut.
Und die haben eine rötliche Farbe und es ist ja so, es gibt einmal diese größeren Formen, die wirklich auch große Durchmesser haben,
es gibt Einschlagkrater, die sehr jung sein können, wo man weiß, da geht noch ein Kamelpfad durch und da ist jetzt ein Krater,
da weiß man, der kann also allerallerhöchstens 2.000 Jahre alt sein, selbst wenn man noch nicht irgendeine Datierung hat.
Und es gibt eben halt auch jüngere Meteoritenregen, wie zum Beispiel im Sudan, vor einigen Jahren, der wurde ja beobachtet
und dann alle Leute, die dort wohnten, sind rumgelaufen und haben die eingesammelt.
Und ich habe ja auch Meteoriten in Nähe einschlagen sehen, also ich habe die gehört, was oft bestritten wird, ich habe sie wirklich gehört
und so weiter, da hatten wir keine Zeit zu suchen, aber diese Mikrometeoriten, die man findet, die wirklich mikroskopisch klein sind,
also weit unter einem Millimeter, die gibt es jetzt, sagen wir mal, fast überall und die kann man auch gut finden.
Und die Spezialisten haben dann so ein rasenmäherähnliches Gerät mit starken Magneten
und dann gehen die nur zehn Meter entlang über eine anscheinend völlig sterile reine Sandfläche und schaben das dann ab unter dem Mikroskop
und es sind fast nur eben Mikrometeoriten.
Das heißt, die sind wirklich extrem weit verbreitet in den Flächen, die eben stabil sind, die nicht ständig zugeschüttet werden.
Und deswegen ist die Sahara wirklich schon ein optimales Gebiet, um nach Meteoriten zu suchen.
Andererseits ist es natürlich extrem aufwendig, weil die das zum Beispiel in Libyen professionell gemacht haben,
die sind ja zigtausende Kilometer in Abstand, also in Sichtweite, abgefahren in einem Gitter, du hast ja einen gigantischen Zeit- und Treibstoff- und sonstigen Aufwand erfordert
und haben über Wochen und Monate da bestimmte Areale abgesucht, und jeden Stein umgedreht, um zu sehen,
ist das vom Menschen hingebrachtes Rohmaterial oder ist das wirklich Meteorit?
Und das ist dann eben sehr aufwändig und heute ja wegen der Unsicherheit auch nicht mehr machbar.
Aber da ist sicher noch viel zu holen.
Und auch wenn wir dort sind, kriege ich also häufig von, gerade in Libyen, dann immer wieder, wo so Meteoritensammler, Einheimische,
die dann auch also zumindest irgendsoeinen Toyota Pickup haben, einem die tollsten Fundstücke anbieten,
aber ich bin nun kein Meteoritenforscher, deswegen habe ich da nie zugegriffen, aber da ist noch viel zu holen.
Aber es gibt ja einen gewissen Markt für Meteoriten, der mag jetzt nicht mehr ganz so ergiebig sein, aber es gibt ja Nachfrage.
Klar, von den Forschungsinstituten, die sind an allem interessiert, weil es ja immer wieder interessante Erkenntnisse geben kann.
So zur Expeditionsrefinanzierung taugt das aber nicht?
Nein, das wäre nur, wenn man ein Maß finden würde und ich meine, wir sind ja nun keine Jäger, die das dann rausschmuggeln
und verkaufen, sondern wir arbeiten natürlich im offiziellen Zusammenhang, so was könnte man gar nicht machen,
aber wir würden sicher da einen großen Anteil behalten dürfen.
Eher am Jäger des verlorenen Schatzes kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ja ein gewisses Interesse auch der Raumfahrt, Wissenschaftsorganisationen, Raumfahrtagenturen,
NASA ist jetzt schon mal genannt worden, an der Sahara, weil sie auch so ähnlich zu sein scheint wie der Mars.
Nein.
Gibt es da irgendwie Kontakte?
Also es ist ja, wir hatten schon Kontakte, vor allem mit US-amerikanische Kollegen, schon Ende der 70er.
Als damals 1978 die NASA eine Expedition finanziert und losgeschickt hat in das südwestliche Ägypten,
die war sehr kurz, war eine gute Woche lang, aber mit hervorragenden Spezialisten aus den unterschiedlichen Fächern
und die waren unglaublich ergiebig.
Also da merkt man, wenn ein wirklich hochkarätiges Team mit guter Unterstützung damals hinfährt,
da findet man manchmal in einer kurzen Zeit viel mehr als man dann mit längeren Expeditionen später findet, wo man mehr ins Detail geht.
So dass man häufig ja sagt, in vielen Fächern, das gilt jetzt nicht für die Archäologie, aber dass man sagt,
also mit zehn Prozent des Aufwandes hat man 90 Prozent der Ergebnisse, und mit den 90 Prozent des Aufwandes hat man dann nur noch zehn zusätzlich Prozent an detaillierteren Informationen.
Das ist sicher sehr vereinfacht und gilt nicht überall, aber die war unglaublich ergiebig.
Und damals hat eben die NASA gesagt, der hieß ja auch praktisch so, dass eben die Landformen, die Geomorphologie
Südwest-Ägyptens ist das beste Analogon zu der Geomorphologie, zu den Oberflächen auf dem Mars.
Und deswegen haben die das finanziert und daran hat sich eigentlich nichts geändert, dass wirklich man die Fotos,
die damals ja noch sehr schlecht waren, die ersten Mariner-Aufnahmen schwarz-weiß und sehr grob
und heute mit diesen spektakulären Fotos, die ja viel besser sind als unsere eigenen Fotos aus der Sahara.
Wir haben da nicht eine Terrabit-Auflösung vom Panorama oder so, also unvergleichlich besser,
aber dass man dort eben wirklich unglaublich viele Ähnlichkeiten sieht, außer dass auf dem Mars eben alles größer ist.
Die Canyons sind viel größer, die Dünen sind viel höher, die …
… Berge alles.
… Berge sind viel höher oder die Vulkane, Berge sind viel höher, die Senken sind viel größer.
Also der Maßstab ist wesentlich größer, aber wenn man den Maßstab weg lässt, dann gibt es Ähnlichkeiten.
Es gibt nur wenige Aufnahmen, die ich bisher gesehen habe vom Mars, wo ich nicht sagen kann,
kann ich euch die gleichen zeigen aus unserer Ecke.
Was heißt denn, die Expedition war ergiebig?
Also was kam denn dabei raus, wenn man jetzt sozusagen diese ganzen Raumfahrtspezialisten mit dabei hat?
Ja, das war halt einfach, dass da hervorragende Geologen waren, die das erste Mal dort waren und viele nur ein einziges Mal
auf dieser ja knapp zweiwöchigen Tour damals, dass die eben halt die geologischen Grundstrukturen schon sehr gut erkannt haben.
Dass andere die Geomorphologie oder die Entstehung …
Manche lagen auch falsch, das ist Teil der Wissenschaft, es ist ja nie jemals irgendwas hundert Prozent sind
und nicht mal in der Naturwissenschaft, in der Geologie und beim Klima, aber auf jeden Fall, dass die erkennen wie die entstanden sind,
dass da Botaniker da waren, hervorragende Botaniker, die in dieser kurzen Zeit schon die wichtigsten Pflanzenarten
und Gattungen identifiziert und beprobt haben.
Dass Fernerkundungsspezialisten dabei waren von der NASA halt, die dann sofort die Ähnlichkeiten herausgearbeitet haben
und die wirklich bis ins Detail gehen.
Also die Sachen, die wir dann durch viele, viele spätere Expeditionen viel mehr ins Detail gehend gemacht haben,
nicht alle zum Glück, wir haben auch viele Neuentdeckungen, aber das war eine ganz tolle wissenschaftliche Grundlage
und die erste wissenschaftliche Untersuchung seit eben der englische Patient in den 30er Jahren und Frobenius
und die ersten Militärs, englische Militärs, die dann praktisch in ihrer Freizeit die ersten Erkundungen durchgeführt haben
und die ersten Landvermesser, also da war ja praktisch eine Lücke von 40 Jahren, wo nichts passiert ist
und das hat einen großen Schub gegeben und ab 1980 haben dann eben diese großen deutschen Forschungsprojekte
an den Berliner Universitäten, an den Kölner Universitäten begonnen, an denen ich das Glück hatte eben meine gesamte Laufbahn,
vom Studenten bis in den Ruhestand, verbringen zu können, im Rahmen von vier Sonderforschungsbereichen.
Das war schon praktisch, also das war schon natürlich ein riesiges Glück, diese Möglichkeiten zu haben
und seitdem ist eben die Forschung der östlichen Sahara also schon weitestgehend jetzt von Deutschland aus erfolgt,
natürlich mit großer internationaler Zusammenarbeit, weil ohne die Spezialisten, die ja weltweit verbreitet sind,
geht ja auch moderne Forschung überhaupt nicht mehr.
Was wir vielleicht noch nicht so besprochen haben, das sollte man vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal reingehen,
dass man ja auch eben sehr viele Tierskelette findet so.
Die dann wahrscheinlich auch einfach so rumliegen, aus denen man ja eine ganze Menge ablesen kann.
Ist das jetzt im Wesentlichen Archäologie oder oder Paläo?
Also wir nennen es Archäozoologie.
Archäozoologie genau.
Das war der frühere Begriff und Archäobotanik für die alten Pflanzenreste oder Holzkohlenreste,
die man ja genau bestimmen kann und gleichzeitig datieren kann, also eine sehr gute Vorgehensweise.
Zum Beispiel meine frühere Kollegin Katrine Neumann in Frankfurt eben da auch wirklich so richtig eingeführt hat in der Ostsahara,
dass man eben, man findet wo Holzkohle, man kann genau bestimmen, was das für ein Baum war und dann datieren,
dann weiß man, in welcher Zeit ist welcher Baum gewachsen, zum Teil viel besser und einfacher als Pollenanalyse,
weil Pollen gibt es ja auch in vielen Ablagen wie in unserem Yoa-See im Nord-Tschad, aber die sind natürlich viel schwieriger,
weil die ja weit transportiert werden können, im Extrem tausende Kilometer.
Und da ist natürlich Holzkohle, ein Baumstamm, der wurde nicht weit transportiert und deswegen ist das eine sehr gute Grundlage,
um die früheren Vegetationsverhältnisse zu rekonstruieren.
Und bei den Tierresten ist es genau.
Manchmal findet man auf ganzen Touren so gut wie nichts und ein anderes Mal kommt man in ein ehemaliges Seengebiet,
wie eben den von uns westnubischen Paläosee genannten See im Nordwesten des Tschad.
Es gibt da keine lokalen Bezeichnungen, weil es keine Menschen gibt, seit Jahrtausenden gibt es keinen Namen,
deswegen müssen wir unsere Namen und die bürgern sich auch erstaunlicherweise dann immer sehr gut in den Ländern früher oder später ein.
Und wo wir den wirklich Zentner von Knochen gesehen und gefunden haben, wo ein See irgendwie,
wurde eben eine alte Seeoberfläche freigeweht durch den Wind und wo man dann fünf Minuten rumgeht
und man eine Quadratmeter große Fläche mit Knochen von Fischen, Nilbarschen, die bis 1,80 groß waren.
Von Flusspferden, von Krokodilen, von sämtlichen aquatischen Arten, die es dort gibt,
und die dort, was man nennt, in einem Deflationspflaster angereichert wurden.
Denn der Wind hat eben den Sand, der drüber lag, immer mehr ausgeblasen und dann diese relativ weichen diatomitischen und anderen Seeablagerungen
und dann reichern sich praktisch die Knochen aus diesem See an an der Oberfläche.
Und da hat man dann natürlich manchmal nach fünf Minuten sammeln einen Überblick über die Fauna, die Großfauna,
eben wie gesagt, 20, an die 30 Arten von verschiedenen Fischen, die dort gefunden wurden, von Schnecken,
von Muscheln, von Austern, von dem gesamten Gehalt und das geht ja runter bis in Mikrofossilien,
eben zum Beispiel Diatomen, diese Kieselalgen oder Ostragoden, diese kleinen Muschelkrebse, die ja kleiner als ein Millimeter sind
und so weiter, und alles ist da zum Teil in der Probe enthalten, die nur eine Hand voll groß ist
und das sind natürlich unglaublich gute Anzeiger über die ökologischen Verhältnisse, die es dort damals gegeben hat über Jahrtausende.
Aber sackt man das dann alles ein oder?
Ja alles natürlich nicht.
Das ist so, war natürlich noch einfacher, früher wo wir mit unseren LKW und Unimogs /unverständlich/
von Berlin gestartet, in Köln gestartet und dann zurückgefahren.
Da konnte man wirklich die ganzen leergefressenen Lebensmittelvorräte tonnenweise auffüllen mit Proben.
Das haben wir auch gemacht.
Die Möglichkeiten sind ja heute viel schwieriger.
Aus Ägypten darf man nicht mal ein Gramm Sandprobe offiziell ausführen, außer mit riesigem bürokratischen Aufwand.
Nicht mal mehr zum datieren.
Die extrem restriktiv sind, weil sie Angst haben, man könnte ja heimliche Exploration machen, was ja stimmt.
Theoretisch könnte man das, haben wir nie getan, ich jedenfalls nie und so weiter.
In anderen Ländern ist natürlich die Probenausfuhr, gerade von archäologischem Material, auch extrem eingeschränkt,
weil das Bewusstsein gewachsen ist.
Früher hieß es, ach alte Keramik, Mensch, wenn die Deutschen es nehmen, gut ist es weg, haben wir sowieso keinen Platz.
Inzwischen ist die Bedeutung der Keramik natürlich sehr wichtig geworden, von Steinwerkzeugen und so weiter
und deswegen kann man aus den allermeisten Ländern, mit wenigen Ausnahmen, auch so gut als Archäologe nichts mehr ausführen.
Oder es gibt eine Fundteilung, nur die Hälfte darf man ausführen, dann wird die Hälfte zurückgegeben, kriegt man die andere Hälfte,
was natürlich es manchmal sehr schwierig macht auf Fundplätzen dann und so weiter.
Deswegen diese goldene Zeit der Probenahme ist eigentlich auch weg, von den Kosten ganz abgesehen.
Denn man muss das ja dann zum Teil mit Luftfracht zurückfliegen.
Das heißt ja, dass dann eigentlich man auf der anderen Seite eigentlich mehr Labor mitnehmen muss.
Das heißt, man muss sozusagen mehr Untersuchungen vor Ort machen, weil man es nicht mitnehmen kann?
Nein, das geht nicht, es gibt nicht die Möglichkeiten.
Man muss so viel wie möglich vor Ort, und die Archäologen zum Beispiel in Ägypten, die fliegen nach Ägypten,
verbringen dort Wochen und Monate, um das Fundmaterial zu bearbeiten.
Also man nimmt es mit, aber man nimmt es nicht aus dem Land raus.
Ich meinte nur, ob man es von dem Ort wegnimmt.
Ach so, man nimmt nicht aus dem Land raus.
Ja, also da ist auch wie gesagt in manchen Ländern viel schwieriger geworden als es früher.
Dagegen zum Beispiel Länder wie Sudan und Tschad, da könnte ich Tonnen ausführen ohne Probleme,
bloß die muss man halt transportieren und versenden, das ist alles auch sehr kostspielig und verpacken und nummerieren
und Listen schreiben, das ist sehr sehr aufwendig, aber jede Probe ist im Grunde Gold wert,
auch wenn ein großes Problem heute entstanden ist, man archiviert ja alles.
Ich meine, das Kölner Stadtarchiv wird für Milliarden alles restauriert, was sehr wichtig und gut ist,
mit den vielen vielen Proben, die genommen wurden, auch in unseren Projekten, wenn dann ein Institutsleiter pensioniert wird,
wenn ein Institut geschlossen wird, kommt ein Nachweis, es ist kein Platz mehr, kein Store, dann wird das Material zum Müll gebracht.
Das sind Proben, die man vielleicht nie wieder kriegt.
Und da müsste es wirklich eine Einrichtung geben, wo man eben diese Proben, die nicht untersucht werden,
die halten sich ja bei uns im Vergleich zur marine Forschung, die ja hunderte Kilometer Bohrkern aus den Ozeanböden haben
und die haben ja auch die Facilitys in Bremerhaven, wo dann wirklich diese zig hunderte Kilometer von Bohrproben
schön gekühlt gelagert sind, das gibt es für die terrestrischen Proben in dieser Weise nicht.
Und die müssten eigentlich aufbewahrt werden, weil dann wie gesagt, auch wenn in 50 oder 100 Jahren jemand das erforschen will,
dann sind die Proben da, wenn die auf dem Müll landen, ist das eigentlich eine Katastrophe, aber man steht vor dem Problem,
also wohin mit den Proben, wie jetzt konkret, wenn die Forschungsstelle Afrika geschlossen wird demnächst,
das sind so viele Proben, die dort lagern, ich kann sie nicht zu mir in den Keller nehmen, also es ist wirklich ein großes Problem mit den Proben,
aber sie sind sehr wertvoll.
Aber es stimmt natürlich, dass immer die zeitaufwendigste Arbeit beginnt, wenn die Proben dann hier in Europa sind
oder halt Übersee und wenn dann die Analyse losgeht.
Und ich sage immer wieder, eine einzige Pollenanalyse kann im Extrem einen Tag dauern,
wenn man den Gesamtaufwand nimmt, vielleicht auch mal zwei, vielleicht auch mal drei.
Aber wenn man dann zum Beispiel wie wir in dem Bohrkern aus Yoa weit über 20.000 Schichten hat,
dann kann man sich ausrechnen, dann braucht man einen Spezialisten oder Spezialistinnen überwiegend,
die das analysieren, von denen es ja kaum mehr welche gibt, weil in der Sahara ja praktisch nicht mehr geforscht wird.
Diese goldene Zeit ist ja vorüber.
Dann kann man sich ausrechnen, welcher Aufwand getrieben werden müsste, um alles rauszuholen was drinsteckt.
Aber wenn man es rausholen würde, hätte man auch einen Datensatz, der weltweit seinesgleichen sucht.
Aber trotzdem, wie gesagt, es gibt nicht die Finanzierung, es gibt nicht die Stellen, es gibt auch noch nicht das Bewusstsein,
wie wichtig manche Analysen sind, und das kann man eben nicht mit einer halben Doktorandenstelle machen.
Oder mit Spezialisten, die schon sehr beschäftigt sind, die zum Teil Leiterinnen von großen Instituten sind
und das in ihrem Urlaub machen oder am Wochenende.
Und da braucht man dann eben die Mittel und die Mittel, wir hatten immer hervorragende Forschungsbedingungen
jetzt seit 40 Jahren von der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft, was die Geländeforschung angeht.
Wir hatten auch natürlich eine gute personelle Unterstützung, was die Archäologie vor allem angeht und so weiter.
Da dürfte sich niemand beschweren, aber es ist halt, wenn man so ganz besondere Orte hat, wie diesen Bohrkern aus dem Ounianga-See,
dann bräuchte man ein eigenes Großforschungsprojekt mit zig Spezialisten und da würde man auch belohnt werden für diesen Aufwand,
aber wie gesagt, es gibt so gut wie niemanden mehr, der seine akademische Karriere noch auf der Sahara aufbaut,
weil es gibt keine Beschäftigung mehr, es gibt keine Forschungsprojekte mehr, es gibt keine Verwendung in den Museen,
auch nicht im Tourismus, auch nicht in Landesmuseen, das wird überall runtergefahren
und deswegen ist also dieses goldene Zeitalter der Wüstenforschung der letzten 40 Jahre, da muss man viel Optimismus haben,
um das in der Zukunft sich wiederholen zu sehen.
Na dann feiern wir doch nochmal für einen letzten Moment die Vergangenheit.
Jetzt sind wir von dieser Archäozoologie ein bisschen abgekommen, aber ich fand das eigentlich ganz spannend,
was dort alles zu finden ist.
Okay, Nilpferde etc., Krokodile, die gab es da ja auch eine ganze Menge, aber es geht ja noch sehr viel weiter zurück,
also man kann da wahrscheinlich auch noch Dinosaurierfunde vornehmen.
Genau, also wir haben auch Saurierfunde gefunden, an vielen Stellen, also viel interessantes.
Also paläontologisches Material, bloß manchmal haben wir die nie wieder gefunden, zum Beispiel weil eben früher,
bevor es eben präzises GPS gab, ohne diese künstlich erzeugten Abweichungen für den nichtmilitärischen Bereich,
haben wir viele Plätze nie wieder gefunden, weil wir eben die Position zum Teil nicht mal auf ein paar Kilometer genau haben,
und manchmal nicht auf 50 Kilometer genau, wenn tagelang Staubsturm war und man keinen Anhaltspunkt hatte mit den schlechten Satellitenbildern.
Also viele Funde haben wir nicht wieder gefunden, gerade ein Saurierfund, den ich gerne wieder gefunden hätte,
schon ein paar Male gesucht habe, aber dann kann da natürlich auch eine Düne drüber gewandert sein
und dann müsste man jetzt 10-20-50 Jahre warten, bis die wieder weitergezogen ist, 200.000 Tonnen kriegt man nicht weggeschaufelt.
Kriegt man nicht weggeschaufelt, nein.
Auch nicht mit einem Bagger, so dass man vieles nicht wiederfindet.
Es gibt zum Beispiel gerade in dem Sandstein, der ein Großteil der Gesteinsschichten gerade in Ägypten und Sudan ausmacht,
das ist ein Sandstein, und Sandstein ist eben immer sehr schlecht, um Fossilien zu finden
und da findet man dann überwiegend Spurenfossile.
Man findet also noch …
… Abdrücke.
… die Abdrücke oder zum Beispiel wie die Trilobiten, die jetzt hunderte Millionen Jahre alt sind, wie die sich eingegraben haben,
und da muss man dann über Spurenfossilien, ganz interessantes Thema, kann man dann schließen auf Tiere,
die man nie als Körperfossilien gefunden hat, wo man dann nur eben das vergleichen kann mit heutigen Formen
von längst ausgestorbenen Formen, ganz interessantes Thema, was man in der Sahara sehr gut machen kann.
Aber es gibt natürlich Regionen, wo man auch hervorragende Fossilien findet.
Ammonite Hills ist eine Region in Ägypten, da kommt man sich also vor wie wir in den besten deutschen Fossilfundplätzen
und Sonthofen oder sonst was, die auch nur zum Teil dann untersucht sind bis heute, aufgrund ihrer Abgelegenheit.
Was für Dinosaurier haben Sie denn gefunden?
Ja, weiß ich leider nicht, weil ich habe nur ein paar Fotos gemacht, Fotomaterial war ja früher ziemlich knapp,
weil man hat ja nur diese kleinen Filmröllchen mit 36/37 Aufnahmen, die natürlich auch teuer waren.
Die haben ja zehn Mark gekostet, Entwicklung nochmal zehn Mark und da war nie genug Filmmaterial da.
Da hat man ein paar Aufnahmen gemacht, heute mit digital endlos.
Klickt man bis der Arzt kommt.
Bis der Arzt kommt, aber keine Aufnahme ist zu viel.
Also im Nachhinein, weil man nie weiß, wie schlecht sie und verwackelt sie ist, aber man hat manchmal Informationen,
also ich habe noch nicht ein Foto gelöscht von allen Digitalaufnahmen, die gehen sicher schon bald in die zigtausende.
Also es war wahrscheinlich ein sehr sehr langer Fischsaurier, aber wie gesagt nur ohne Probenmaterial.
Also ich habe auch Knochen, also ein paar Dinosaurierknochen mitgenommen von anderen oder Saurierknochen von anderen Fundplätzen,
die kann man dann ziemlich genau bestimmen, also so ein Riesensaurier war noch nicht dabei,
aber wenn es Familien gibt, dann muss es dort natürlich auch größere gegeben haben, aber wie gesagt,
die müssen natürlich jetzt Millionen von Sandstürmen überlebt haben in diesen Stellen, wo ich die meisten
oder einige gefunden habe und so weiter.
Und da müsste man natürlich auch systematisch suchen und dafür hat man eben praktisch nie die Zeit.
Wenn die Zukunft der Wüstenforschung jetzt so ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen ist, weil zu teuer, zu aufwendig, keinen interessiert es
und man kann das Zeug nicht mitnehmen, okay, gut, das sind Bedingungen, die könnten sich ja vielleicht auch wieder ändern.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen wird es mal wieder interessant, man will da irgendwas finden, wo man weiß,
ah das liegt ja alles in der Sahara rum und das wäre jetzt mal total wichtig, Beispiel habe ich jetzt gerade nicht parat.
Könnte zum Beispiel ein Meteorit sein, dass man irgendwie irgendetwas ganz besonderes nochmal finden möchte
oder eben auch im Bereich von Dinosauriern, so nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott wir haben da eine ganz grundlegende bahnbrechende Erkenntnis,
wo könnten jetzt nochmal größere Mengen rumliegen, oh ja zack Sahara.
Man könnte ja auch drüber nachdenken, genauso vorzugehen wie in dem vergleichbaren Bereich, der auch sehr schwer zu erreichen ist,
nämlich dem Mars.
Da fährt jetzt mittlerweile ein VW großer Wagen herum, atomgetrieben, liefert bestechend scharfe Fotos und hat sehr viele Gebiete schon bereist.
Hat ja im Prinzip auch ein ähnliches Umfeld dort.
Also man könnte ja sagen, man nimmt jetzt mal Curiosity und passt ihn quasi für Sahara-Verhältnisse ja.
Also ist natürlich nicht alles gleich, wir hatten ja schon gesagt, so von der ganzen Formation her alles sehr vergleichbar,
aber natürlich ist es viel viel heißer, weiß nicht, Sandstürme gibt es halt auch auf dem Mars, aber das ist natürlich in der Sahara nochmal ein ganz anderes Problem, egal.
Aber es sind ja irgendwo auch alles lösbare Probleme.
Könnten Sie sich das vorstellen, dass man so einen Roboter einfach losschickt in die Sahara?
Also ich denke, das ist die Zukunft.
Der einfach da automatisch alles abgrast, jeden Meteorit einsammelt, ja im Prinzip auch gleich ein Labor dabei haben könnte?
Absolut.
Also ich denke, ich weiß nicht, ob so eine Generation kommt, die halt auch bereit ist, so wie die unserige.
Jetzt rede ich wie so ein alter Soldat oder so, die halt unter diesen harten Bedingungen auch noch arbeiten.
Wie gesagt, ich habe seit Jahren riesige Probleme Mitfahrer zu finden, also mit fachlichem Hintergrund und so weiter.
Und ich denke, das ist die einzige Zukunft.
Man muss natürlich sagen, es ist eine ganz andere Liga die Marsforschung.
Es sind Beträge, da fällt man in Ohnmacht, wenn man die vergleicht mit den Mitteln, die für die terrestrische Wüstenforschung vorhanden sind.
Aber es würde ja schon mal der Raketenstart wegfallen.
Aber das ist die einzige Zukunft.
Es ist auch viel billiger in dieser Hinsicht.
Genau, nein ich denke, das wird kommen.
Und ich kann mich erinnern, dass Lonnie Thompson, berühmter Gebirgseisforscher damals bei Clinton war,
wo es darum ging, eben so ein Massenspektrometer zu entwickeln, damit man nur einen halben Meter Bohrkern
auf dem Mars untersuchen kann, einen halben Meter.
Und der dachte dann immer, was hunderte Millionen kostet Entwicklungsarbeiten und wo er sagt,
mein Gott mit einem Bruchteil, mit einer Million könnte ich schon die ganzen Gletscher der Erde erforschen bis zum geht nicht mehr,
aber da konnte er nicht eintauschen.
Aber wenn diese Technologie so fest ist und wie gesagt, auch weil die Wüste ruiniert alles, fast alles.
Es gibt ganz wenige Geräte, die mehrere Touren durchhalten.
Schweizer Messer, das kann dann natürlich knirschen und nicht mehr aufgehen, aber das sind so die wenigen Ausnahmen,
die viele mehrere Expeditionen überstehen können.
Elektronik ist extrem anfällig, da ja dieser feinste Staub, der ist ja fast wie Wasser und selbst wenn man doppelt und dreifach verpackt,
macht man auf, kommt was rein, setzt es aus, es wird zu heiß und so weiter.
Aber wenn diese Geräte so entwickelt sind, jetzt auch über die Marsforschung, dass sie wirklich autonom, eben solargetrieben,
ausgerüstet mit unheimlich vielen Analysemöglichkeiten vor Ort, da gibt es ja riesige Fortschritte in den letzten Jahrzehnten,
dann wird das so kommen und dann lässt man die loslaufen.
Also solange keine Düne drüber geweht wird oder sonst was, also ich würde sagen, die werden auch kaputt gehen,
weil es extrem raue Bedingungen sind, aber wenn die so abgekapselt sind, so perfektioniert sind,
dann sitzen wir am Bildschirm und sieht schon die Auswertungskurven der Ablagerungen.
Natürlich bis es solche gibt, die dann 25 Meter oder 16 Meter lange Bohrkerne ziehen oder jetzt riesige Löcher graben,
das ist also nochmal eine größere Liga.
Technologisch machbar wäre es und dann könnte man natürlich auch viel mehr in die Fläche arbeiten.
Umgekehrt für die Meteoritenforschung, das hatte ich schon vor über zehn, fast vor 20 Jahren angedacht,
dass man eben zum Beispiel auf dieser Selima Sand Sheet, diesem großen flachen Gebiet, Sandgebiet im Nordwest-Sudan,
wirklich solargetriebene Roboter loslaufen lässt, die eben halt systematisch das abfahren, wie heute so ein Rasenmäher
und die dann zumindest lokalisieren und dann man dann nachher hingeht und automatisch die dann geprobt oder halt einsammelt.
Also das wäre sicher heute schon möglich.
Aber es ist schon ein großes Unternehmen und so ein paar Roboter, die da rumfahren, reichen eben nicht.
Ich sage mal, nur der Selima Sand Sheet hat die Größe Bayerns oder größer.
Die müssten ja auch wirklich engmaschig das abfahren, und da kommt man dann gleich wieder in Größenordnungen,
wo man wahrscheinlich dann abertausende, wenn nicht zigtausende bräuchte.
Außer für Stichproben wäre es sicher möglich.
Aber ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, wie das mit dem Mars funktioniert und ich meine, es gibt viele Nachteile,
die der Mars eben hat, die so jetzt in der Wüste eben nicht da wären.
Also erst mal das Funkdelay, man muss ja immer extrem langsam unterwegs sein, nicht weil man die Energie nicht hätte,
sondern weil man immer wieder stoppen muss, gucken muss, nachdenken muss, was ist unser nächster Schritt?
Und vor allem wenn halt in irgendeiner Form da mal die Kommunikation abreißt, dann ist irgendwie auch alles gleich vorbei.
Wenn das Ding jetzt in der Wüste da hängenbleibt, okay, dann könnte man halt tatsächlich mal …
Mal hinfahren oder Drohne.
… mit dem Hubschrauber oder keine Ahnung, also mit einem Flugzeug da landen und das Ding mal irgendwie reparieren,
dann ist man wieder weg, das hat zwar ein bisschen Geld gekostet, aber muss man jetzt keine Rakete für starten.
Nein, das stimmt.
Die Dinger könnten mit großer Geschwindigkeit unterwegs sein, man kann halt irgendwie die Daten auch relativ schnell abgrasen
und hätte da eigentlich ganz interessantes Ding und ist ja sonst irgendwie auch niemand da, der einen irgendwie groß stören kann,
abgesehen natürlich jetzt von dem Sand und das sind dann natürlich wiederum Herausforderungen, wo man sagen kann,
naja so eine Maschine zu bauen, die Sand widerstehen kann, Sie sagten wie Wasser, also wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Fast so fein, es dringt überall ein.
Wir haben auch wirklich zum Teil so Behältnisse, die sind für Taucher und selbst da, weil man macht auf und im Auto und geschützt unter einer Decke,
also Kameras halten selten mehr als eine Tour durch, also ob das jetzt Filmkameras sind oder Fotokameras
oder empfindliche Geräte, geophysikalische Messgeräte, es ist unglaublich anfällig,
weil eben Staub und Sand, Sand jetzt geht noch, Sand ist ja nur bis 63 Mikrometer groß, aber der Staub,
der halt wirklich bis in die Atomfraktion reingeht, dann dringt das überall ein, ein-zwei Mikrometer die kommen überall rein
und da ist halt Elektronik sehr empfindlich.
Und dann kommt die Hitze dazu und die mechanischen Belastungen auch, es wird den ganzen Tag rumgeschüttelt in den Geländefahrzeugen.
Also die Belastungen sind extrem und wie gesagt, die Wüste frisst fast alles, auch Autos und sonst was.
Aber sicher ist alles machbar.
Wenn jetzt Elon Musk oder Larry Page jetzt sich dafür begeistern, da wäre unglaublich viel möglich.
Bloß es müsste halt gezielt sein, jetzt glaube ich für Meteoriten weiß ich nicht, ob sich das mal lohnen wird.
Aber eben wenn man jetzt einfach überlegt, dass die Sahara ja wie gesagt in paläoklimatischer Hinsicht eine unglaubliche,
noch wenig beachtete Quelle der Erkenntnis ist, dass es ja immer hieß in den 80er oder vor allem 90er Jahren auf der Basis eben der Eisbohrkerne in Grönland,
dass man sagt, das Holozän, das Nacheiszeitalter, die letzten 10.000 Jahr grob waren stabil
und wo der sagt, gut vorher ging es rauf und runter mit den Temperaturen, mit allem, wie man das eben in Grönland sieht
und dann guckt man in die Sahara und sagt, was die Sahara ist heute die größte trockenste Wüste?
Und die war mal fast komplett grün und belebt, also einen dramatischeren Klimawandel kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
und der nimmt ein Drittel des afrikanischen Kontinents ein.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt, wenn jetzt wirklich eben die globale Temperatur anthropogen bedingt,
ausschließlich glaube ich nicht dran, also viele nicht, aber mitbedingt, dass sieben Milliarden Menschen auch das Klima beeinflussen
und wenn es dann wirklich global wärmer wird und die Ozeane erwärmen sich und die Monsunwinde verstärken sich
und der Gegensatz zwischen den Kontinenten und den Weltmeeren wird verstärkt und es wird viel mehr Wasserdampf wieder weit über die Sahara getrieben
und dann bilden sich wieder Wolken, die abregnen, dann würde ich sagen, wiederholt sich das,
was beim letzten Mal am Ende der letzten Eiszeit vor 11.000 Jahren schon mal passiert ist.
Und das würde natürlich einen verstärkten Forschungsaufwand durchaus rechtfertigen,
denn das wäre eine positive Auswirkung, die man ja geologisch greifen kann.
Die muss man nicht modellieren, das wird kein Mensch bestreiten heute, dass die Sahara weitestgehend grün war,
dass es fast überall in der Sahara geregnet hat, wo es heute nicht mehr regnet.
Und dass natürlich ein Drittel eines so großen Kontinents wie Afrika ja dann auch Auswirkungen hat auf den Rest der Erde
und dass ja dieser Wüstengürtel, in der Sahara sieht man es am besten, aber das, was in der Sahara passiert,
ist ja im Prinzip übertragbar auf die Saudiarabische Halbinsel, durch Pakistan in die altweltlichen Wüsten
eben bis hin in die zentralasiatischen chinesischen Wüsten, dann ist das scho nein riesiger Raum,
wo glaube ich die Paläoklimaforschung eigentlich jetzt erst das richtig große Gewicht bekommen sollte
und nicht so als handliche Forschung im Vergleich zur marinen Forschung, die auch unglaublich wichtig ist,
natürlich die Ozeanböden sind immer noch viel unbekannter als die Sahara an der Oberfläche,
da hat man ja jetzt die fantastischen Satellitenbilder, das ist ganz klar.
Aber ich denke, nach diesen Jahrzehnten von den Forschungen in den Polargebieten wäre es wirklich an der Zeit,
mal auch diesen Aspekt dieser Bedeutung dieses idealen Forschungslabors sozusagen anzuwenden für die Prognostik
und für die Klimamodelle und auch zur Überprüfung der Klimamodelle.
Und da haben wir schon festgestellt, dass eben so manche Klimamodelle, die für die Vergangenheit gerechnet wurden,
eben nicht so zutreffen können, weil es eben nie eine schlagartige Austrocknung der Sahara gab,
sondern das war ein ganz kontinuierlicher Prozess und da würde ich sagen,
aus unserer Sicht ist der aufgrund der archäologischen und geologischen Befunde steht der felsenfest
im Gegensatz zu numerischen Modellen, wo natürlich nur wenige Faktoren berücksichtigt werden können,
die dann entsprechende Fehler haben.
Also kurz und gut, im besten Fall kommen dann die Roboter, die dann noch viel mehr Daten liefern auf die Fläche über die gesamte Sahara.
Irgendwann, ich werde es, glaube ich, nicht mehr erleben oder sicher nicht erleben
und damit könnte man halt dann dieses riesige Areal natürlich noch viel mehr auswerten.
Auch mit ganz neuen Ansätzen, es gibt ja ständig neue Methoden, wo viele dann das nicht bringen, was erst mal erhofft oder versprochen wird,
dass sie immer mit einer neuen Methode sagen, jetzt haben wir den Stein der Weisen für Fragestellungen gefunden
und nach ein paar Jahren stellt sich dann doch raus, oh so gut war es doch nicht.
Da gibt es ja dann viele Unsicherheiten und Jahrzehnte später wird dann die ganze Methodik wieder weggelegt und so weiter,
aber wenn es irgendwelche neuen Ansätze gäbe, die man in diesem großen Trockenraum eben dann untersucht,
da kann viel rauskommen.
Aber man sollte es machen in Gebieten, die völlig menschenleer sind, weil sobald irgendwo Menschen sind,
werden die sicher das tollste Gerät sofort einsammeln, um sich da irgendwas draus zu basteln.
Okay, da darf man nicht hin, aber wir haben ja schon festgestellt, es gibt ja da genug Bereiche,
wo Menschen einfach mal gar kein Interesse haben groß zu bleiben oder selbst wenn sie das Interesse hätten,
einfach keine Möglichkeiten das zu haben.
Und ich denke, man kann das ja auch sportlich sehen.
Ich meine, es gibt die Rallye Paris-Dakar, die ist eh schon so ein bisschen aus ihrer Zeit gefallen.
Die gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Wir sind jetzt sozusagen schon kurz in dieser Ära, wo autonome Fahrzeuge versuchen, durch unwirtliche Gebiete durchzukommen.
Da kann man dann auch gleich durch die Sahara fahren und nebenbei auch noch einen wissenschaftlichen Nutzen davon ziehen,
dann ergänzt sich das in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also man hat da mehrere Anreize.
Ich sehe das alles mal wieder ganz optimistisch.
Nein, das muss man, das ist gut.
Stefan Kröpelin vielen vielen Dank für den erneuten und noch tiefergehenden Einblick in die ganzen Aspekte der Wüstenforschung.
Ein sehr buntes Feld.
Sehr gerne.
Und das war es dann hier mit Teil 2.
Und ich bedanke mich für’s Zuhören, das war es bei Forschergeist.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.